This is Jocko podcast number
81 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
November 29th,
it has teamed
the trenches or ankle deep.
Some places calf deep in
mud and the communications
trenches are rushing streams
of brown water.
The men are wet through,
but stick the job like Britain's and
I hope for their sake that the weather
lifts with the morning.
But guns have been strafing today though.
Up Til now we have dodged the show.
It may be ours again tomorrow though
one never knows.
This is from the diary
of Captain Charlie May,
the British Army Officer Commander of B
Company 22nd Manchester Pals Battalion
of the Manchester Regiment
who served in World War One.
He was married to Bessie Mae
and they had one daughter
who was born July 20th,
so she was a little over a year old
when this journal was being written
from the trenches
and it continues December 1st,
1915 it is exciting work.
Sniping in fact,
one must curb the tendency lest
it should become a fascination.
The second in command of the e Lance,
the East Lanchester regimen and myself
putting a couple hours this morning and
had quite a bit of fun worrying
the batches in their trenches.
One fellow was walking across the open
2000 yards off when I spotted him and let
go. You never saw a chap
move quicker in your life.
Okay.
He ran for a tree and jumped behind
it and I let him have four more there.
Whether I got them or not,
I don't know,
but he didn't move for the next half hour.
I know because I waited
so anxiously for him
last night or rather one 30 this morning.
I got outside the barbed wire
and got lost three times.
I had to fling myself
down in the wet grass,
bury my nose in it and grovel while the
machine guns went chattering over me.
Yeah,
it is remarkable with what speed one
learns to adopt the prone position.
January 13th,
I long and long to see you to clasp you
in my arms and I long with all my heart
to see my baby,
how I love her.
What hopes I have for her.
What a sweet girl she will make.
February 25th,
1916 woke up this morning to find the
snow pelting down and covering the ground
fully five inches deep.
Also,
it was freezing hard cotton. A fellow
officer came in to breakfast with us.
He brought the Little Bible which another
soldier had taken from the body of a
dead German
on the fly leaf in a child's handwriting.
The word Dada
war is very sad.
Perhaps the man may have done and
been something to loathe and detest.
I do not know.
All I am conscious of is that somewhere
in his father land there is a little
child who called Him Dad.
Dad.
Okay.
April 6th,
1916 fritz strafed our new trenches with
heavies and searched around the support
with hg shrapnel and other
such an obnoxious stuff.
Okay.
One shell claimed three
NCO and wounded three men.
We all feel wild to get at the beast
and I hope we may string them up on the
wire.
I saw the kill to go down the line.
It was a pitiful sight.
Poor boys.
Shell fire is a horrid thing.
Grasty a lad who was a
sergeant of mine was the worst.
His body full of gaping holes.
It was very,
very sad.
Do those at home realize how
their boys go out for them?
Yeah,
never can they do enough
for their soldiers?
Never can they repay the debt they owe.
Not that the men ask
any reward,
but one day we'll get
at him with the bayonet.
We'll take our price then for Gretzky.
Okay,
and all the other hundreds,
thousands Gretzky slain as they
were standing at their posts.
Okay.
June 17th,
I do not want to die.
The fought that I may never see you or
are darling baby again turns my bowels to
water.
My conscience is clear that I've always
tried to make life a joy for you,
but it is the thought that our baby
may grow up without my knowing her and
without her knowing me.
I prayed,
God, I may do my duty for I
know whatever that may entail,
you would not have it otherwise.
June 23rd,
1916 everything is speeding up to no end.
Okay.
Ammunition by the hundred
wagon load is pouring up.
It should certainly not be for lack of
ammunition if we do not make us huge
success of the venture
yet one cannot help feeling
a little anxious and worried
so much depends on this great throw.
Yeah,
and what he's talking about there
in this part of the journal,
it reflects the buildup for
the battle of the Somme.
Yeah,
and although Charlie doesn't know exactly
when the battle is going to commence,
they're obviously only distributing that
information with people that have the
need to know. They know that
a major attack is forthcoming
then that's why they've got all that
ammunition piled up more than they could
ever think they could possibly need.
Back to the journal.
June 28th
okay.
the moment seems very
auspicious for us to strike.
Perhaps we will on Friday.
Okay.
July 1st,
we marched up to the
assembly trench last night.
The most exciting march imaginable.
Guns all around crashed
and roared till some times.
It was quite impossible
to hear oneself speak.
It was however a find site
and one realized from it
what gun power really means.
Fritz of course strafed back and reply
causing us some uneasiness and a few
casualties before we
even reached the line.
The night past noisily and
with a few more casualties.
The Han puts a barrage on us every now
and then and generally claims one or two
victims.
It is a glorious morning.
We go over in two hours time.
It seems a long time to wait
and I think whatever happens,
we shall all feel relieved
once the line is launched.
No Man's land is a tangled
desert unless one could see it.
One cannot imagine what a terrible
state of disorder it is in,
but we do not yet seem to
have stopped the machine guns.
These are popping off all along
our pair of Pitt as I write.
Yeah,
I trust they will not claim to many
of our lads before the day is over.
Now I closed this old diary
down for the next few days.
Since I may not take it into the line,
I will keep a record of how
things go and enter it up later.
Well, yeah, that update
never took place
and Charlie may was wrong about how
many British soldiers would be claimed
before the day was over. He didn't think
he would claim to many, but as you know,
the first day of the battle of the Somme,
July 1st turned out to be
the worst day in history
for the British army
and they suffered almost
60,000 casualties,
60,000 casualties in one day.
Then like I said,
those casualties included Charlie May,
who went over the top
on July 1st under the
cover of allied artillery.
He was leading B company
and he didn't.
His men fought their way
across no man's land.
And just as they reached German lines,
Charlie was a hit by shell fire.
They had killed
in his diary,
was found by the man that eventually
dragged him back to the trenches private
Arthur bunting
who mailed the diary
to Charlie's wife Maude
now,
or the British have a
steep military history
and obviously this is the kingdom that
we Americans rebelled against and the
revolutionary war. And we fought
them again in the war of 1812
yeah.
And we actually had a bunch
of other little various
disputes with them until the
late 18 hundreds
when during something called
the great reproachment. Yeah.
Through various forces in the world
are political objectives or aligned.
And we became the staunchest of allies
with Great Britain through World War One
and world war two and Korea and Vietnam.
And even up til now in
Iraq and Afghanistan.
And I've been lucky enough to work
alongside Brits on just a couple occasions
while I was in the military.
And there's no doubt that they are
just outstanding troops professional in
everything that they do.
When they leave that impression on you,
you can actually feel the pride
of their military tradition.
And
tonight I wanted to take at a,
I look at a book that is part
of that military tradition
and the book is called
serve to lead.
And I'm going to start with some
statements from the introduction to this
version of the book.
And the version of the book that
I'm reading is the old version.
I think it's from 1954 or 57 originally
written right after World War Two and
these comments here are from
a guy named Robin Matthews,
a former British army officer,
graduate of the Royal Military Academy
of that's like the British west point.
He went on to command his regiment,
the light drag goons,
which included a tour of duty in Iraq in
2005 he also served with 16 air assault
brigade in Helmand
province in Afghanistan.
And here's what he has
to say about this book.
Serve to lead is a remarkable book
produced by the Royal Military Academy
Sandhurst.
After the Second World War.
It is as clear and concise a treaties
on leadership as you will find.
It also provides a fascinating glimpse
into what sets the profession of arms
apart from any other
serve to lead is synonymous with Sandhurst
placed on the bed of every officer
cadet at the beginning of
their military training.
Somewhere between prayer book,
which is what I fought,
it was initially and Bible as
it has often been referred,
it lays out what is expected and
what to expect on equivocally.
It establishes selflessness,
self discipline, integrity,
and duty as the bedrock of leadership.
Excitingly,
it speaks of courage and boldness as
the essential differentiators upon which
events turn and to which soldiers
and leaders are instinctively drawn.
There is so much to enjoy
and consider on every page,
but the most beguiling message
of the book concerns humility.
Okay.
Leadership must be confident,
but unless it is matched in
equal measure by humility,
it jars at which point
the lead simply fall away.
If I am to lead you, first and
foremost, I must be your servant.
Okay?
Like any good book, the clue
is in the title. In this case,
simple,
seemingly contradictory,
but ultimately profound serve to lead
and that's the intro to this book
and obviously there's a dichotomy of
leadership.
He's already talking about things that
we talk about all the time and yes,
you've got to be confident but you've got
to be humble and the title of the book
is a contradictory is a dichotomy
in its own sense, right?
Serve to lead. No, and like I said,
this book, they actually have a
new one. Then I have the new one.
I went with the old one and the
reason I went with the old one,
there's a couple of things
that we're going to play.
I'm going to point out that clearly
they've changed their faults on and maybe
we'll end up doing a compare
and contrast with the new one.
There aren't that many differences,
but there certainly are some
very significant different
differences and we'll
get to those
and this is going to kick off with a a
piece from the Lord Bishop of Durham.
It is the fact that some men possess an
inbred superiority which gives them a
dominating influence over their
contemporaries and marks them out.
Unmistakably for leadership.
This phenomenon is as
certain as it is mysterious.
It is apparent in every association
of human beings in every variety of
circumstances and on every plane
of culture in a school among boys,
in a college among the
students in a factory ship
yard or mine among the workman
as certainly as in the
church and in the nation,
there are those who with an assured
and unquestioned title take the leading
place and shape the general conduct.
So there's an opinion and people ask
all the time, are leaders born or made?
That one right there is,
hey, leaders are born
and that's I, I always say
both. I always say there's,
there's certain leadership qualities
that people are born with and some people
are born with a lot of them. Some people
are vulnerable, all of those qualities.
Some people are born with a lot less,
some people aren't born with any,
they're not going to be much of a leader.
He doesn't matter how much you train them.
You can get them better,
but they're not going to be a
great leader and obviously some,
some leaders don't need much training.
Uh,
there's very few of those
leaders that just don't,
they just get it out of the
gate as just born that way.
I think it's a mixture of both and I
think you're born with some leadership
capability and the more you hone it,
the more you work on it,
the better you're going to be.
Why would you think or
why do you think that is?
Because to be a leader,
like the good,
strong qualities that you got to have
or still contradict or counterintuitive,
they're not even counterintuitive, but
the, you can get better at all of them.
You know, a couple, the
one that's, for instance,
some people are naturally talented or
some people are naturally articulate
people,
so they're able to get their
message across in simple, clear,
concise language. That's very important.
Now, if you're born with that,
you're lucky, right? Good
job. You are born with that.
You were born in articulate
person. If you weren't, guess what?
You're going to have to work at it.
You're going to have to read,
you have to write,
you have to listen,
you have to practice speaking to
people and you will get better at it.
So those, that's your example. Some
people just have it naturally and,
but even people that have it naturally,
we'll get better at it over time.
I was always pretty
comfortable speaking to people,
but obviously when I was in the military,
I spoke to people all the time.
And when I was in a training training
situation as a young enlisted seal,
I was put up in front of classroom to
speak to people and I got better at it.
And then when I became an officer and
a leader now I was briefing people.
And so I'm doing it even more.
And then I took over the training for
the west coast seals and now I was
briefing people all the time. And, and
when I was overseas, I was briefing,
you know, colonels and generals and okay,
you're going to brief a bunch of times,
you're going to get better at it.
I was already okay at it just naturally,
but I got better at it and I'm
still getting better at it today.
So that's the same with any of
these particular talents, you know,
being able to simplify things,
being able to detach.
Those are all important
leadership qualities.
You can have a certain level
that you're capable at,
but the more you practice them, the
better off you're going to be. Yeah. Yeah.
So it's a combination. Yeah. So
we'll have you say like there's,
it's pretty rare that you get
somebody who's, um, you know,
just has all the qualities right
out the gate. Yeah, no, I see.
I've never met anybody that just,
just dominates.
And every category like detaching
for example, that's not,
that's kind of counter to
your natural way. That's true.
Most people are going to want
to get in there for sure.
Now I just thought of this example.
I've talked about him a little bit on the,
on the podcast where we had Tim Ferriss
on all the lead Grizzard he was, uh,
he was the,
he was my assistant platoon commander
when I was at seal team one and he got
murdered. It was horrible, tragic
situation. He was involved in a murder,
suicide and, but he, he had
a lot of those capabilities.
He had a lot,
like he was articulate,
he was the quarterback at
the navy football team.
So we had like a real good
presence to him. He spoke clearly,
he was down to earth
and yet, you know, very,
he could elevate himself very quickly
when there's talking to them, you know,
if he needed to elevate himself.
He just had a lot of those
qualities very naturally. And,
and guess what, he was at the
Naval Academy, he played football.
He was constantly getting in front of,
you know,
getting in the huddle and telling
guys what was going to happen.
And you get good at that over time.
And part of that is so,
I don't know how much of it,
you know,
I didn't know him when he was a football
player when he was in eighth grade,
maybe he was stammering and trying
to put his thoughts together,
but then he trained it over and over
and over again. And he got better at it.
And maybe by the time he got to
me as a 23 year old lieutenant Jg,
he was like, oh, we're
going to get in a huddle.
I'll tell you guys what's
going on. And so, you know,
even though it appeared to me like
it was natural, probably wasn't,
it was probably trained, you know,
he had some national capability,
but he played football his whole
life. And that was that. Yeah. So in,
in a way you can kind of,
and this may be kind of interchangeable
as far as the expression, but you know,
you say natural capability.
It could be that they gain it
through learning or whatever,
just through their environment, you
know, like as a kid, you know? Yeah.
So playing football and then they'll
bring it to the training situation and
they'll excel. But I think it's
gotta be a little bit of both. Right.
And you will get better at it, but the
more you focus on that particular skill,
like some people aren't very
comfortable talking in, in, you know,
even they're not even comfortable talking
in a conversation. Right? Oh yeah. Yeah.
And so if you end up with a kid like that,
well you got to get 'em out and
socialize them and get them in,
get them in front of people talking all
the time. And that will be good for them.
Yeah. If you have someone that's,
uh, if you've got a kid or, yeah,
if you've got a kid or a young leader
that doesn't know when to shut up,
right. How are you going to, cause
sometimes leaders are like that too.
They want to hear themselves talk and
they just keep talking all the time.
And guess what? The more you
talk, the less people listen.
So if I'm giving orders on every little
thing that we've gotten to do in front
of us, eventually you're
not listening to me anymore.
And when something critical comes up,
you're still not listening to me cause
I've been talking for the past six
straight months won't shut my pie hole.
So that's a bad situation.
So how do we get that
person to quiet down?
It's both. Yeah. All right.
So now we're going to hear from a
guy named Field Marshal William Slim.
I think bill slam is what
they ended up calling him.
And he was in World War
One and World War II
wounded multiple times,
I think three times led the 14th
army in Burma and World War II.
And he also fought with the Anzac.
So the,
the Australia New Zealand
Army Corps at [inaudible].
So you could say he's got a pretty good
view of things. Sure. So
he's this, believe it or not,
the first this, this book kicks
off with talking about morale
and the morale of the troops.
So here we go.
Back to the book morale
as a state of mind,
it is that intangible force which will
move a whole group of men to give their
last ounce to achieve something
without counting the cost to themselves
that makes them feel that they are part
of something greater than themselves.
Now this is interesting. So, so he's
talking about the importance of morale.
Now going back to the subject
we were just talking about,
back to the book I learned too,
that one did not need to be
in order to be effective,
two things only were necessary.
First to know what you were talking
about and second and most important to
believe it yourself.
So there you go.
You don't need to be great orator,
but you gotta know what you're talking
about and you've got to believe it. Yeah,
those are two really good places to start.
He continues on talking about morale.
He says up a most potent
factor in spreading this
belief in the efficiency of an
organization is a sense of discipline.
We tried to make our
discipline intelligent,
but we were old fashioned army
and we insisted on outward signs.
We expected soldiers to salute
and officers salute in return,
both in mutual confidence and respect.
I encouraged all officers
to insist whenever possible,
and there were few places where it was
not possible on good turnout and personal
cleanliness.
It takes courage,
especially for a young officer to check
a man met on the road for not properly
saluting or for slovenly appearance,
but every time he does it adds to his
stock of moral courage and whatever the
soldier may say he has respect for
the officer who does pull him up.
Now this is an interesting point, right?
Because what we're talking about here is,
oh, I see echos, you know, not
wearing his uniform correctly,
so I'm going to go over
and tighten you up.
That is, you can see where you can see
where people are probably thinking, yeah,
Joc will be all over that guy,
right? No, actually wrong. That's a,
that's actually wrong.
And what we're going to talk about here
is I'm going to talk about what I called
leadership capital.
You only have so much leadership capital
in your bank and you've got to decide
what as a leader,
you're going to spend that capital on.
And if I see you out of uniform
or you're looking sloppy,
I've got to decide if it's worth me
investing my leadership capital and going
over and telling you that you
need to tighten it up. Hey Echo,
you need to get that.
Hey, Sergeant Charles,
you need to get your uniform squared away.
You look like crap.
You're setting a bad example.
Is that what I want to invest
my leadership capital on
now? Can it be sometimes?
Yes, absolutely. And we've
talked about the many cases
where that occurs. You know,
when you look at at Hackworth,
when hack words showed up to
Vietnam as a battalion commander,
he tightened up their uniform
standards immediately.
He tightened them up immediately.
He knew he needed to invest
that leadership capital.
He needed to start with a small things.
But if you're in a garrison situation
and you see somebody that maybe isn't
doing there,
isn't wearing their uniform properly and
you decide you're going go tighten them
up, I'm not, I'm not saying it's the wrong
answer. And as Leif Babin will tell you,
it's not what you preach.
It's what you tolerate.
And so if you tolerate the
guy's looking like crap,
they're just going to continue going
down that hill of looking like crap.
Now to me, there's a certain point, right,
that I won't let you go past
if you're a little out of the,
out of the standard made me, I'm going to
let that one slide a little bit, right?
But once you get to a point where you're
looking like crap, well guess what?
I am absolutely going to tighten you up
and I'm gonna explain to you why it's
important. I'm just going to go
and yell at you. No, not happening.
So you've got to be careful
how you ration your,
your discipline and your
leadership capital, right?
If you just run around yelling at
everyone or getting in everyone's face for
every little thing that they're doing.
Pretty soon you could look at that like,
well pretty soon they'll have, they'll be
scared of making a mistake. But that's,
that's the point.
Now you've got people that are scared of
making a mistake now cutting off their
ability to end their
desire to think freely.
So the bottom line with this balance,
you got to stay balanced in these things
and don't waste your leadership capital.
I was talking to a guy the other day,
he was running a offsite for his
executive team and I talked to him and,
and he said, man, you know, it was just
junk. And I said, well, what happened?
And he had showed up to the executive
offsite and he's in the company and he's
the guy that's running the off
site and he gets there and he says,
all right guys, now while
we're here, no cell phones.
So everyone put your cell phones away.
We need to focus this a strategic meeting.
We need to,
we need to get this done.
So the guys put their cell phones
away and they start the meeting. He's,
he says five minutes into the meeting,
the CEO breaks out a cell phone,
starts looking at it a minute after
everyone sees that you got half the room
looking at their cell phones and he
went like, got kind of nuts on them,
you know, this is man,
what's what's going on?
And people aren't even
paying attention to.
After the first at first hour he
said this, you know what's going on?
And I said to him, I said, Bro, let's
look at what you just so then he said,
then he lost them. Like the, the meeting
just went downhill. And I said to him,
let's talk about what you did because
you invested your leadership capital for
this important meeting on telling
people to not use their cell phones.
Did you tell him why?
He's like, not really.
Did you explain to them when they would
be able to use their cell phones? No,
I didn't.
So you just went,
now this company is a financial company.
They've got a lot of things going on.
You can imagine the CEO of a big
financial companies got a lot of important
calls and emails to check and all that.
And all of a sudden he gets told no
cell phone. What does that going to end?
What important thing is happening at my
company today where I'm not allowed to
talk on my cell phone and
answer emails or look at,
look at my emails and I'm the
guy. So, so when am I supposed to,
when would I be able to look at it?
You didn't tell me that.
So he invested all of his leadership
capital to get people to do no cell phones
and he spent it and there wasn't
any left and, and the, you know,
so you have to be careful. Now you have
to approach it the right way, right?
First of all, you could
say, hey listen guys,
we're going to power through a solid
hour right now. I'm going to ask you,
unless it's just critical,
keep your cell phones put away
and let's power through this.
Let's get some good
conversation going. Right? And,
and in an hour we're going to take a 20
minute break where you can catch up when
you got to catch up on,
and then we'll do another hour after that.
So now people understand what's
happening and they understand why. I'm,
by the way, you know, if we, if
everyone's on their cell phones,
we're not going to get what
we need out of this meeting.
So you've got to explain and you don't
want to invest your leadership capital on
things that don't matter.
So if you're the senior guy
in a leadership position
and you're focused on some
little person that's out of uniform,
and that's what your focus is,
that's, that's not a good
focus to have, right? Yeah.
You should set the standard and your
subordinate leadership all the way down to
the front where you've got like you
and me, our peers, and I don't let you,
I'm the one not,
I'm not waiting for the boss to
come by and tighten up your uniform.
I won't let you tighten up. I won't
let you wear a crappy looking uniform.
That's what I want.
I want to have a gang mentality where
we're self policing because the minute I'm
from the top doing that again,
does this happen sometimes? Yes.
I'm not setting out a, a black
and white rule here. Yeah.
I'm giving the broad guidance that if
you're Hackworth and you're taking over
battalion where people's lives are at
risks and you know that there's slack
everywhere and they're
not doing a good job,
you got to go in there
and tighten them up.
And one of the best ways to do that is
to go in there and start on the small
things.
But if you've got a functioning unit that
there's nothing critical happening and
you're trying to build that team
into something that's, that's, uh,
a winning team and the first thing you
could do is go in and focus on some of
these small things when you haven't
really established yourself,
that could be problematic.
So think about those things
when you're in those positions.
Alright.
Going back to the book,
I do not say that the men of the
14th army welcomed at difficulties,
but they grew to take fierce pride
in overcoming them by determination.
Any ingenuity from start to finish,
they had only two items of equipment
that were never in short supply their
brains and their courage.
They lived up to the
unofficial motto I gave them.
God helps those who help themselves.
Okay.
Handle. Once again, that's the same
thing that colonel bill reader said,
got to help yourself right now we're
going to move on to still still talking
about morale.
We're going to talk to or to hear
from Field Marshal Bernard Montgomery.
If you don't know who that
is. Monte World War One,
the Anglo Irish war,
the Palestine conflicts that
disbar uprisings and World War II.
He,
you know, obviously ran the British Eighth
Army World War II. So we've, once again,
we've got a person with some very solid
perspective on leadership and combat
leadership. The quality of
morale back to the book. In war,
the moral stature of some men increases
and their characters grow stronger and
more closely knit in proportion
to the discomforts and dangers.
They are called upon to face.
Boom. So some guys get better.
Some guys rise to the
occasion back to the book.
Such men will occasionally
perform in battle.
Remarkable acts of selfless courage
and daring and will endure with
extraordinary fortitude and patience,
the burdens frost upon them,
other men.
However,
we'll under the stress of hardships or
dangerous surrender to fear or fatigue
and allow their characters
to disintegrate.
This disintegration,
we'll usually take the form of
a loosening of the moral fiber,
which results in timidity of
Action and slackness in appearance.
While those who have gone to seed will
be dirty and their appearance will be
sluggish and we'll be
slovenly in these later cases.
There has been a general
loosening of character due
to partial surrender to fear.
So I totally agree with this.
You see,
in combat situations,
people either get better
or they get worse.
Some people just kind of cruise
right, stay in that same zone, but,
but some people they get better when they
get worse. They rise to the occasion,
know where they fall back to the book.
The good soldier,
the man with high morale has not
surrendered to fear and has maintained his
personal standards.
The bad soldier,
the man with low morale has become
incapable of independent action and has to
some extent shed a part of
his human individuality.
That's an interesting,
that's an interesting statement that the
person that's incapable of independent
action, he saying he shed some
of his human individuality.
Back to the book.
Basic factors of morale.
We now must considered
the factors con what?
What factors constitute morale of
the soldier in the heat of battle?
Certain factors may be described as
essential conditions without which high
morale cannot exist.
These four basic factors are one,
leadership to discipline,
three,
comradeship and for self respect.
A fifth factor,
devotion to cause must exist but need
not necessarily influenced all the
soldiers.
Finally,
there are numerous contributory factors
which are of great importance but are
not essential conditions.
Starting with this first one.
Leadership morale is in the
first place based on leadership.
Good morale is impossible
without good leaders.
Human beings are fundamentally a lichen
that certain common characteristics
apply to all men in
varying degrees in battle.
The most important of these
characteristics is fear.
All men are afraid at one time or
another to a greater or lesser extent.
In moments of fear,
they band together and look for guidance.
They seek for a person to give decisions.
They look for a leader,
okay?
The leaders power
of decision results from his ability
to remain calm in the crisis.
His greatest asset is the ability to
act normally in abnormal conditions,
to continue to think rationally
when his men have ceased to think,
to be decisive in action when
they are paralyzed by fear,
a little bit of normal face from Monte
abnormally in abnormal conditions remain
calm
back to the book.
The object of training must be first
to select those who possess them within
them. The potentiality is
of leadership and secondly,
to develop these potential realities.
This is accomplished by giving
the leader responsibility.
The leader's character will develop in
proportion to the responsibility with
which he has been entrusted.
Trusted. So there you go.
He's saying the same thing that we
just were talking about earlier.
You have certain potentials
and you got to develop those.
And how do you develop them with people?
You give people,
you want to develop leaders,
you give him responsibility.
You don't give him responsibility
that's going to kill them,
but you give him responsibility that's
gonna definitely test them and they're
going to have to step
up to be able to perform
back to the book.
That two vital attributes
of a leader are a decision,
inaction and be calmness in crisis.
Given these two attributes of
key will succeed without them,
he will fail our great problem
in pieces to select leaders.
It's just select as leaders,
men whose brain will remain
clear when intensely frightened.
So from Monte, you gotta remain calm. Hmm.
Now he's going to talk about discipline.
The object of discipline
is the conquest of fear.
There are two aspects of fear.
Fear can suddenly attack a
man through his imagination,
a corpse in a ditch or a grave.
By the SARC far side of the road
will remind him of his position.
He will suddenly realize that he
himself is liable to be killed.
It is a function of discipline to fortify
the mind so that'd becomes reconciled
to unpleasant sites and accepts
them as normal everyday occurrences.
Fear can also creep upon a man during
periods of monotony on the line.
At such time,
he will have the opportunity to appreciate
the dangers which beset his life.
Fear acting through his thoughts can
so reduce the man's hardcore of courage
that he will become nervous and fearful.
Discipline strengthens the mind so that
it becomes impervious to the corroding
influence of fear.
It teaches men to confine their
fought within certain definite limits.
You didn't steals the habit of self
control. That's pretty amazing.
It's pretty amazing assessment to think
that the one of the best premier tools
to overcome fear as discipline.
Hmm.
Back to the book.
Discipline implies a conception of duty.
Nothing will be accomplished in the
crisis by the man without a sense of duty.
Makes Sense. Now he's going to talk
about comradeship. Back to the book.
Morale can not be good unless men
come to have affection for each other.
A fellow feeling must grow up,
which will result in a
spirit of comradeship.
And Army is made of human beings so that
however much a leader may inspire as
men,
however perfect the discipline,
the morale will be hard and unsympathetic
if the warmth of comradeship has not
been added.
Oh yeah,
you gotta be,
you gotta be the hardcore disciplinarian,
but you need the warmth of comradeship.
Back to the book war though hard
business is not necessarily a grim one.
Men must laugh and joke together,
must enjoy each other's company,
company and must get fun out of even life.
I must get fun out of life
even in times of danger.
So do you want to have a good time?
Yes you do.
And the thing that makes these dangerous
times more bearable is when you're
having fun during them.
And that's one of the things that you're,
I don't talk a whole lot about seal
training in here on the podcast,
but one of the things that you do in
seal training is you're doing miserable
things cold, wet, tired. And you're having
fun the whole time you're learning that,
hey, guess what? I can sit here
and be cold and it's miserable.
Or I can be cold and I can laugh about
it and I can make fun of my friend.
The way he's shivering.
That's what makes it bearable.
And the same thing happens when you get
overseas and you joke about really dark
things,
you know,
dark sense of humor that comes out
real strong when you're overseas.
And one of my,
one of my buddies who was super paranoid,
I've talked about them
on here before the guys,
the guys found a tube that had
shipped like maps or something.
And if you pulled the
tube apart real fast,
it sounded like a mortar
law of mortar launch.
And so they'd get outside is 10
and he was super paranoid. We,
we spent a little bit of time getting
mortared and so he was a little on edge
from that. Yeah. So they'd go
outside of his tent, you know,
and you can hear through the 10 it's
just a little piece of fabric and they go
outside of his tent and they'd pull that
thing and it would sound like a mortar
through Qut freaky, you know,
what the hell are you cross doing?
Or you know,
at first you hear him like fall and like
say hit the ground and then you'd hear
the giggling of the guys and then
you'd hear him cussing everyone out.
But uh, yeah, but it was fun. It was
funny too far. A little too far maybe.
But everyone's having a good
time and even him, you know,
we'd get done and he
would be come outside,
you guys are bastards
and we'd laugh about it.
That's the kind of thing where you're,
you've got to have fun in these tough
situations. Yeah, that makes sense.
That's probably why, you know, like
nowadays, like Contemporary Company,
they in court, like Jade's company,
frack mom, take up foosball,
ping pains.
I heard,
I heard massive noises of the other day
and I was kind of sounded like like a
mortar fire and wasn't quite mortar fire,
but there was something,
I didn't know what it was and they were,
they were in a,
in a nerf gun firefighters.
And by the way,
it was sloppy. Like no one knew
what they were doing. Yeah.
There was no cover and move happening.
It was just all, every man for himself.
I was pretty disappointed. What
the fuck? The reason, right.
Where it's not, I mean these are, I
mean conceptually it's the same thing.
Obviously it's way different.
It's way different,
but it's not actually not right when
you're going through tough things in a
business and our company,
we have fun with it.
And when I work with
companies that are good,
good companies and they're
going through something tough,
the ones that have good morale,
the ones that are laughing,
they're the ones that do better.
Who wants to go to work if you don't
enjoy the people you work with, you know,
like why would you want to do that?
You know, one of the, one of the, uh,
I hate even calling it the worst job,
but I was the animal's age, right?
So every day I'm wearing a uniform,
I'm in sitting at a desk all day.
I did it for 13 months. It was
just that part of it. It's,
it's, you know, even it's just
a miserable job. Right. Luckily,
first of all, the animal is a great
guy and I had a lot of, you know, we,
I joked around all the time with him and
his executive assistant is a guy that I
would literally not,
I would go two or three weeks at a time
and we wouldn't say one serious thing to
each other. I just, everything
would be some joke about every,
all the misery that we were going through
and my misery. I just mean, you know,
hours worth of meetings and traveling all
the time and he'd been on the road and
staying and crappy hotels and flights
getting bumped and canceled and being held
over in the,
the animals suitcase,
not showing up somewhere and
he's supposed to go on stage.
It doesn't have a uniform with them.
And like that's, you know, not fun.
But guess what I had found the whole
time and we'd be joking about, you know,
I'd say,
well I guess I'm going to get take,
take one and again for the team
and we'd be just laughing. So yeah,
even in these situations that aren't
fun at have you gotta have fun with them
and that definitely will
help out your morale.
And if you're in a leadership position and
all you do is just bare, you know, get,
get drown in the misery
that you're going through.
Every single person that's with you is
going to be going through the same thing.
And so as a leader you got to,
once again,
going back to the dichotomy of leadership,
you gotta have, you gotta know when,
okay, the guys were under too
stress. They're not having
fun. I need to have fun.
I need to start a nerf war in the,
in the office here.
So guys loosen up and then there's times
where hey guys are having too much fun.
We got to tighten them up. Yeah, yeah.
Like, hey guys, we got this to do.
And so you got to ride that, that line
in balance it out correctly. Yeah.
Yeah.
It's cool.
Hall like newer companies that were
companies nowadays there are incorporating
that element into the, the
actual co, you know you're right.
And there's companies nowadays that do
it too much and all of a sudden they
can't get anything done.
Yeah they're messing around because
everyone's playing ping pong. Right.
Everyone's in the Lego room cause they
got rooms now where it's like oh you
could go in there and think and do play
with legos cause that relaxes your mind
I guess. Not me when I'm around lake
goes I think I'm going to step on them.
Sorry cause I got kids stepped on late.
Legos is a nightmare.
So I don't like being around Legos.
I got the PTSD from Lego stepping when
I was glad my kids were younger. Lego,
you know, cause you can't ever get your
son enough legos apparently. Correct.
Cause they just need everything.
And when I was a kid there was not
that many different types of Legos.
You had blocks,
long ones and shorter ones.
Nowadays you get Lego's but they have
hands and horderves and machine guns and
they got cool stuff but
they ain't Lego's anymore.
They're little toys but they still come
with the little legos and they still
hurt the bottom stuff on.
They are surprisingly sharp for kids.
Made your choice major sharp.
All right,
going back to the book,
he's the other thing you talked about
self respect and no man can be said to
possess high morale if the quality of
self respect is lacking and this is
something that Dick
Winters talked about too,
that self respect and
and how that drove him.
Soldiers must be encouraged to respect
themselves at all times and under all
conditioned.
Self respect implies a determination to
maintain personal standards of behavior.
A man who respects himself will allow
neither himself to become slovenly nor has
quarters dirty.
Even in action.
He will take care to see that his
personal appearance suffers as little as
possible.
It is the job of the noncommissioned
officer to maintain this aspect of
discipline.
It is the function of the officer to
encourage and instill self respect.
So
interesting. He breaks that down a
little bit. Like I was talking about.
If I'm the senior guy and
I'm around yelling at people
about how they're looking,
that's not good.
That should be my subordinate leadership
should be tightened in that stuff up.
Yeah,
no. Okay. Here's this conclusion. Again,
this is Monte talking.
In brief,
high morale has been defined as the
quality which makes men ender and show
courage in times of fatigue and danger.
The cultivation of morale depends on the
training of leaders and of discipline.
The encouragement of comradeship
and the infusing of self respect.
The leaders must have a belief in their
cause and they must pay attention to
numerous contributory factors of
considerable but secondary importance.
We live today in a scientific age,
but we soldiers have to remember that
the raw material in which we have to deal
is men.
Man is still the first weapon of war.
His training is the most important
consideration in fashioning of a fighting
army. All modern science is
directed towards his assistance,
but on his efforts depends
the outcome of the battle.
The morale of the soldier is the
most important single factor in war.
So there is Monte,
and that's,
that can be said for just
about any organization,
what your organization is made
up with his people. And you know,
you hear that with businesses
all the time. Our people,
our most important assets,
that's generally going to be the case.
Hmm.
Okay.
Here's some, now we get into the
leadership, the actual leadership section.
Interesting. Again, they start off
with morale. That's the first chapter.
Now they move into leadership
and you know,
clearly from what he just said,
Morales,
the most important thing and
winning battle. I don't agree.
I think leadership is the
most important thing. Now.
His number one is number one.
Uh,
factor in good morale is
leadership. So I guess, you know,
you could see where we're coming
from a different angle, but my,
my font is a little bit different.
My thought is the most
important thing is leadership.
And I think that leadership
covers other things.
Just be besides the morale of the men,
because now we're talking about
the strategies that you're using,
the tactics that you're using.
Everything is covered by leadership,
including morale.
Yeah.
So you guys are looking
at it from not opposite,
but just varying perspectives where he
thinks leadership is part of morality.
You think morale started leadership?
Yes.
I think you have identified the
situation correctly. All right.
Here's some more from Monte on leadership.
I would define leadership as the will
to dominate together with the character,
which inspires confidence.
Okay?
A leader has got to learn to dominate
the events would surround him.
He must never allow these
events to get the better of him.
He must allow nothing to
divert him from his aim.
He must always be on top of his job and
be prepared to accept responsibility.
So Montes,
talking about ownership.
Now what I have to caveat this with is
you get these people that are single
minded,
right?
And that they're going to dominate
everything that's going on around them.
And they do that from a
tactical perspective, not
from a strategic perspective.
So, for instance, if you say, um,
I must never,
or I must dominate the events
which surround me and must
allow nothing to divert
me from my aim,
that can actually be problematic if it
doesn't make strategic sense. Right?
So if I'm always worried about dominating
everything that's going on around me
and the thing that's going on around
me isn't really that important,
I'm wasting my time on
it. Yeah. So this has to,
this has to be sort of offset a little
bit by the dichotomy of leadership,
which is, yes, you want to
dominate what's going on,
but if what's going on isn't important,
you need to let it go.
You need to just let it go a little bit.
Hmm.
All right, so now we're going to hear
from Jen. And by the way, this book,
what this book serve to lead,
it's, it's basically a bunch,
I should have said this in the beginning,
but it's,
it's a bunch of small excerpts, bigger
than quotes. Some of them are just quotes,
which I don't do a bunch of like, hey,
just reading quotes. I'd do a couple,
I'm going to do a couple of
today, but some of them are
like, you know, two, three,
four pages of people's
views on leadership,
of which I'm pulling out some of
the highlights. And interestingly,
for the first time I was going
through some of this and I was like,
you know what? I'm actually,
it was something that I've,
it's something that I've said a million
times. And so I said, you know what,
I'm not actually going
to highlight this again
because I've said it over and over
again. Now, clearly with discipline,
I just talked about it for 47 minutes
and I probably always will when I get the
opportunity,
but there's a lot more about discipline
as a whole section on discipline.
We'll get to, all right,
now we're going to talk,
we're gonna hear from
General John Hackett again,
a World War II African campaign
as part of market garden,
which is the big airborne operation,
the World War II than here's what he says.
I am a soldier.
In speaking of leadership,
I do so as a soldier and when I think
about it as any soldier often must I do so
in the context of battle
pressures in battle are high
and in battle. As a consequence,
the problems of leadership stand out in
bold relief and that's something very
similar to watch what I say,
which is combat is like life amplified
and intensified wrote that an extreme
ownership and that's what I'm talking
about. And because it's that way,
it's very easy to identify what's going
on with the leadership. It's a very,
the problems of leadership
stand out in bold relief.
He said it better than
me back to the book,
but while battle may be unique,
the problems that it exposes our not
yeah,
right?
Yes.
Leadership problems and had been working
for seven years with other companies
and people that are not to battle.
And guess what the problem is that battle
exposes are not unique to battle for
leadership is concerned with getting
people to do things and is most keenly
needed when difficulties,
doubts and dangers or at their greatest
in whatever sphere this is attempted.
The problems are essentially similar.
So anytime you've got a team,
you've got to try and
make him do something.
The problems are pretty
much going to be similar.
Back to the book I said that leadership
was concerned with getting people to do
things. What I meant was getting
them to do things a willingly.
So we don't want to just bark
orders at people that doesn't work.
Doesn't work in business,
doesn't work on the battlefield.
Will it work for five minutes?
Yes it will. Will I get,
I yell at you and get you
to do something. Yeah, sure.
You're right on monster.com looking
for a new job and then you get home.
Yup.
Back to the book of Man really only
gets a full response from the men.
He leads by something approaching complete
fusion of his own identity with the
hole that he and they together form.
So think about that.
If you're in charge of
something and you're a leader,
you need to become that thing.
You need to become that team.
You need to become that goal.
I liked that one.
And you can see when people get possessed.
Like you look at the modern business
leaders today, those are people that,
you know,
Steve Jobs,
he was like obsessed with the
product that he was apple.
And that's one of those
things that was so beneficial.
Ilan mosque just like he is
what he's trying to do. Yeah.
Back to the book,
successful military leadership is
impossible without the leaders total
engagement in the task in hand and to
the group committed to his care for its
discharge. And what's interesting about
that, I was talking to your brother, uh,
Jade Charles, I'm not too long ago
actually. It was pretty long ago. And He,
and he said something to me and it was
like a big revelation to him and he was
very,
is a very,
he had a good way of saying with what
I'm just reading about right now.
We were talking about something,
he was going to a meeting and
he was going to be, you know,
talking about something.
There was some controversy about
where they were going to go and,
and he said that the person
that cares the most wins.
And that's a great statement.
It's very true.
It's not a hundred percent true,
but the percentage is very high up there
because if I just care about something
so much and I'm going to drive with it
further than you if I care about this
decision more than you do.
Yeah.
I got a really good chance of winning
really good chance of winning. Yeah.
Couldn't seem to like that translates
into any. Yeah, and he'd go more.
You care about it. The more
probability. Yeah. I guess the only,
the only place where it becomes
problematic is if I, uh,
I care about something, you know, at 97,
level 97 and you care about
with the opposite decision,
you're also at level 97. Oh
Dang. Now we've got an issue.
Now we've got a problem because we're
both going to think we're going to win and
we both believe that we need to win. So
now it's going to, going the distance.
Now we got an ego scenario going on
and things become problematic and,
and you know where this just
becomes stupid as in the,
when you hear people having political,
I would use an air quotes on that one.
Political debates around
something. Yeah. You know,
and this person totally believes 100%
and this person totally cares 100% and
they're going to go nuts on each other
and they don't listen to anything that
the other person says.
And you ended up with a big disaster on
your hands of nonsense. A lot of those,
whether it be political diet,
that's another one. Yeah,
I know. I was listening,
I was listening to our podcast.
Sure ain't worries.
And what we were talking about,
we were talking about,
I was talking about watching people in
the news and that's a classic situation
where you know, you got somebody on a
three minute segment and one person is DB,
you know the hardcore this direction.
The other person is the hardcore and
the other direction. They both care.
They both care a lot. Neither one of
them is going to win. They actually,
that that goes the next,
that's the next realization is that if
you're going up against person that cares
as much as you do, you actually have to
take a back step and find another way.
You have to flank them.
Yeah.
Cause you're not going to be able to win
them by going head to head they care or
is it equal to you and you've got
to find a new solution. Otherwise,
you know what you'll do, expend all
your ammunition, charging machine,
gun nests and you'll die that
you don't want to do that.
If you care as much as me and
I don't have the same opinion,
I've got to flank you. Yeah. A lot of
these probably going to let you think.
You just won the argument in order to
flank you too, by the way. Yeah. Yeah.
The um, again, political religion,
diet, how to raise kids, you know,
all of these are all hot button.
Is that what you call it?
Things that you're not supposed to talk
to or talk about around the Thanksgiving
dinner together, they get
heated real quick. Then you,
and a lot of times we're talking
about, you know, people are not people,
but we've talked about how much
someone cares about it, right?
A lot of times the things they get mixed
up is how much you care about it versus
how much you care about your stance on it.
Any different but and,
and different. And then you've got
to put your ego into both of those.
Because my ego, I don't want to admit that
I'm wrong, right? That was still to do.
That means you care about your stance.
So when you make it by yourself,
but if you care about the
issue, like if I, if I,
if me and you were having a debate
about kettle bell workouts or something,
I like dumbbells Kettlebell,
but I really care about the issue and
the issue is what's the best, right?
If I truly care about the what,
the best exercises and not about my
stance on what the big w I'm going to care
about the real answer, read that.
Whether it's my answer or not.
So that's why I think like political, all
these other things, they have the end.
It is, it's just like how you
said it's the ego natural thing,
but they wind up carrying
more about their stance on it.
Then they do the actual issues,
you know for sure.
Don't let that happen and watch
out for that one. So yeah,
the [inaudible] 96 [inaudible] 97 but the,
the person who cares the most wins doesn't
apply to someone's individual stance
on something. It applies to subject.
And it also doesn't apply to, you know,
a Jujitsu match.
Cause I might really care about winning.
I was thinking about this the other day,
cause that's another thing people
say mental, oh it's all mental.
And here's an example.
Alex Honnold,
who's a rock climber who just
climbed El Capitan in Yosemite,
which is 3000 feet tall.
And you people say, oh,
it's all mental. And, and
people say things, you know,
if you want something bad enough, you
can do it. You put me on that rock,
there's a some crux move like
2000 feet up, 2000 feet up.
That's really hard.
And you're smearing,
which is this technique and
rock climbing where you don't,
and I've done it before and
I'm like the lowest white belt.
I'm not even a white belt.
And like I like someone gave me my white
belt in rock climbing or you, I'm not,
I'm not like a legit,
but I know I've tried things.
I go to Yosemite and I'll play
around on the rocks and everything,
but I've tried this thing,
it's called smearing and,
and you're basically just using the
tread or just the bottom of your rock
climbing shoes on flat granted.
And you can create enough
friction that you can,
you can move up it and some
people are really good at it.
I suck. And you know, you've got to have,
you've got your hand
holds your work and to,
but you're using your feet and it's this
really weird balance that you have to
do because if you push too hard and
the rocks, they, your feet slip off.
And if you don't push hard enough,
you don't get any lift.
So it's this really fine like
balance you've got to have.
And apparently there's one move or this
one series of moves on this climb that
he did that you see, you have to smear it.
Of course, this is very natural for him,
but apparently he climbed that section
with a rope like six or seven times just
to make sure it felt good and
all that stuff. Here's my point.
Even if it wasn't a smear print,
even if he was just holding on
to rocks right at 2000 feet,
I would absolutely want really,
really badly to hold onto the rocks.
I don't have the muscular
strength to do it.
I mean the things that he's holding
on to our smaller than will,
the first pad of your fingers.
That's what he's holding onto a tiny,
and we were doing this the other day at my
house, remember? Yup. That little thing,
you actually had bet had
stronger grip than me on the,
on the climbing board that I
have at my house, but I could,
I could couldn't even hold on or
I could hold on for five seconds.
And you like had no, it did you hold
on to the really small one? Yeah. Yeah,
that's legit.
I can't even hold on to that thing.
So if I was 2000 feet up and I really,
really, really, really, really,
really wanted to do it, and I was
all mentally in the game, guess what?
I'm falling into my deaf because I
don't have the strength to do it.
I don't have the physical strength
and I need to build it and okay.
You could say, and that might
be an acceptable answer. Okay.
If you really have the mental
strength and will to do it,
then you'll trade train super hard.
But at that moment, not gonna help me,
I'm falling to my death. Right. Yeah.
I think that's not a
metaphor, but like, uh, it's,
it's like it's me. Yeah. That would be,
oh yeah, it's a romantic thing. Yeah.
You want it bad enough you can do it.
No, actually not true. I want to do,
I want to take the extreme version.
I want to stay alive.
I'm 2000 feet up. I want really badly
to stay alive. It doesn't matter.
I can't get across that section. I can't,
don't have the hand strength to do it.
Not happening, but they're making a
movie about that. I can't wait to see it.
About Alex Honnold climbing that rock.
Jimmy Chin is the famous
kind of photographer guy
that they went and documented
the whole thing and apparently one of
the articles said that during that crux
moment, Alex Honnold was like,
Hey, when we get to here,
just like back off with the cameras.
He apparently was like, ain't no,
just back off the cameras when I go
through, you know, section 94 alpha,
because I think he thought he didn't need
any cameras around real close when he
might fall to his death.
It's that heavy. Yeah,
like W W we'll or is it because it
might break his concentration or both?
I Dunno. I Dunno, but that's
crazy. Have you ever been Yosemite?
No,
it's,
it's El Capitan is 3000 feet straight
up of granted it takes people three,
four,
five days to climb up it.
He climbed it and three hours and 45
minutes with a chalk bag and a pair of
shoes. It's ridiculous. It's
ridiculous. It's ridiculous.
It's completely ridiculous.
3000 feet.
That's very tall echo. You're trying
to imagine it. Let me help. No,
I'm taller than anything you've ever seen.
It's taller than,
than a skyscraper in San Diego.
It's huge and he climbed it with no ropes.
That means there's no rest.
That means there's no break and
it means there's no mistakes.
You can't make a mistake if you make
a mistake, you die. Yeah. Crazy.
Very impressive.
I don't even know why we're talking
about Alex Honnold right now. Oh,
because we're talking about
the mental will. Whoever
believes that the most. Yeah.
Whoever believes the most
wins cares about it. Sorry.
I don't believe in as much as
I care about staying alive,
I wouldn't be able to pull it off.
Yeah.
I think in jade situation that it did
make sense though. You know, cause you're,
you know, actually that does
make sense. It does make sense.
And that's why I was able to do a lot
of stuff that I've been able to do in my
career.
When I was in the military,
a lot of the stuff that
I was able to get done,
I was able to get done because I
cared about it more than anybody else.
You think you're going to,
you know,
you think you're going to outperform my
task unit. I care about this so much.
I don't care.
I care about this so much.
You're not gonna be able to compete
with me because you might think, oh,
I'll get there at five o'clock in the
morning. I've been there for an hour.
You might think I'm going to
have my guys drill this 10 times.
I'm gonna have my guys drill it 20 times.
I care about this too much for you to
win. You can't beat me. You can't beat me.
It's not going to happen. I care
about this too much. Not in a bad way.
Not in a selfish way. I care about this.
I love this. This is everything to me.
You don't know.
You have other things going on and you
got your wife and you got your family and
you've got this other thing going on
in your life and you got goals that you
want. I don't care about any of those
things. This is all I care about,
so therefore you can't compete with me.
And that's pretty cool.
It's a cool place to be,
right and get overseas.
People aren't thinking about
all these other things now.
You don't care about anything.
I don't care about anything else.
This is the only thing I care about.
So it ends up getting boiled
down to just not stopping. Right?
Not quitting, not giving up. Yeah.
That definitely plays a role.
That definitely plays a
role. I am, of course,
there's gotta be balanced because if,
let's say, I don't care about, let's say,
you know, my, my focus is
100% my seal task unit,
but then I forget about the fact that
we're working with our other army units.
The only thing I care
about is my unit. Well, no,
actually I need to care about
the mission more. Right?
I need to care about our strategic,
where we're going strategically.
Because otherwise I'm thinking,
I just want to get my guys taken care of.
I just want to get my guys more work.
I just want to get, no, actually I,
I do what care.
What trumps might care for.
The task unit was care for the mission
of what we're trying to accomplish.
Now luckily those two things
are completely aligned.
So there was never any time
where I was thinking, oh,
should I do this to benefit the task
and or benefit the mission? No, no.
If it benefited the mission
to benefit the task unit,
if it benefited the task and your
benefit benefited the mission period.
So I care about those things. Begin
to have a hard time competing with me.
And luckily in Ramadi, there wasn't any
competition. We were all working together.
That's what was so amazing about
it was army Marine Corp us,
everyone was just working
together to accomplish missions.
Cause that's what you get when
you get a nasty battlefield.
You get people working together.
All right,
another piece.
This is a guy named general mom.
Sell.
War is preeminently the art of the man
who dares to take the risk of the man who
thinks deeply and clearly of the man who
when accident intervenes is not there
by cast down,
but changes his plants and disposition
with the readiness of a resolute and
reflective mind which so far as is
possible has foreseen and provided against
difficulties. There you go. That's
what we're talking about. Oh,
accident intervenes. Cool. Good. Yeah.
I'm not cast down.
Change plants adapt.
Okay.
Back to the book.
No.
Now no man can inspire confidence in
others who is not confident in himself and
self confidence comes from knowledge.
A thorough understanding of modern
weapons and organization tactics and the
details administration affecting all
those under his command must therefore be
acquired by every leader. He must show
his troops that he can plan, sound,
be lead resolutely and deal promptly
and effectively with the unexpected.
In addition to gain full
confidence of his troops,
a leader must have their
personal friendship and trust.
Yeah,
I like that. Again, I've, there was a,
there was a seal officer that once
was briefing guys and said, Hey, if,
if your guys, if your,
if your people like you,
they then they, uh, you're
not doing a good job. Yeah,
not true.
He's actually saying they need your
trust and personal friendship and trust.
Yeah.
Once you seen something like that,
that even that you can't
push that too far. Well,
of course bounce dichotomy of leadership.
You can't be such close friends that
you're choosing that you're putting one
person as more important
than the mission or the team.
That's the dichotomy of leadership.
Thank God.
Okay.
Now he puts together this list,
which yeah, we're, we're, we're
feeling pretty good about this one.
A short list to leadership
given as follows. Perfect.
Your military knowledge study,
the use of weapons.
They're tactical handing the enemy's
character and methods and way to make use
of ground. So I don't care what job you're
in. Apply those, right? No. Your tools.
No the enemy. Know your competitor.
Next, study the men under your command.
Know them well and be known to them.
Gain their confidence by your
knowledge, energy, and skill,
and by your interest in their welfare.
Always be cheerful with them.
However, you may feel, teach
yourself to think out. Reason.
Depreciation's leading to
clever but uncomplicated
plans quickly and unhurriedly
so there you go. Keep things simple. Know
your people. Get the I like it, says.
Know your people. Get them to
know you too. That's important.
Next study methods of deception
and make full use of them.
Always aim at misleading the enemy.
Always seek surprise.
Keep your object clearly before you
concentrate your efforts and resources at
the decisive point.
Always think well ahead.
Yeah,
prioritize and execute.
Work out the best methods of control,
different tactical situations.
Practice them constantly.
Study the situation carefully.
Don't waste any time.
Make up your mind and stick to it.
Get out your orders quickly.
Make certain that everyone clearly
knows what you intend it to be done.
Commander's intent.
Maintain the initiative.
Make opportunities and seize them at once.
I liked that.
Make opportunities. Boy, do I like that.
Don't wait for them to come.
Be prepared to take risks,
but don't be foolhardy.
No,
your commanders intentioned and act in
accordance with it. Don't wait for orders.
Inaction is always wrong,
so there you go. Well,
this is just reiterating things
that I talk about all the time.
Never take counsel of your fears.
Think of the enemy's difficulties and
how you can take advantage of them.
Remember that it is willpower
that wins. Oh, he's,
he's going off w not talking about caring.
He's talking about will,
which will goes along way,
never relaxed your efforts
until victory is won.
Attend to the comfort of the troops
before you think of your own.
This is all just phenomenal stuff.
Be loyal to your superiors
and your subordinates.
Express your views clearly and frankly,
but when a decision has been reached,
fully support it and stop all criticism.
Never take shelter behind others when
things for which you are responsible have
gone wrong.
Take some ownership.
Oh, I like this one. Refrain
from jealousy, resentment,
and self seeking.
Be Tactful.
Never make friction.
Be Thoughtful and considerate,
but maintain from discipline.
Think about how bad this thing
about the dichotomy of that.
Be Thoughtful and considerate,
but maintain from discipline.
Never ordered troops to do what you
are not prepared to do yourself.
Never give an unnecessary order.
That's a good one.
Think about that one.
Never give an unnecessary order and
I'll tell you why I liked that one is
because if you're doing
a good job as a leader,
orders should barely even be necessary.
They should barely even be necessary.
I talked about this with life
the other day. I, I'm weak.
I'm sure we could go back through,
you know the history
of tasking at bruiser,
but as we were having a conversation,
we were working with a company.
I don't think I ever gave an order to
either one of my two platoon commanders,
either life or the
Delta platoon commander.
I don't think I ever said this
is what you're going to do.
That's an order like you see in the
movies. Right. I'm going to ask you,
they say that. Did they ever say
that? You say in order if you yes,
it can be set. I'm trying to
think. I'm sure it's been, I,
I think it's been said to me before,
no more like an Admin,
like not administrative situation.
Patch.
I don't know if anyone's ever said it
to me before, like that's an order.
I don't know.
I'm trying to think of,
there's been some situation where
someone said to me like, Hey,
basically like you've pushed
far enough Jocko stand down.
Like I've gotten one of those
before. Like, Hey, we get it Jocko,
you care about this a lot. It's not
happening to stand down. I've gotten some,
especially got those when
I was a little younger,
like when I was a young enlisted guy,
the driving with an id,
I just be wanting to crush it and, and
people would be kind of saying, Hey,
well no we can't. And I'd be like, no, why
can't, why can't we? Why, why, why, why?
Why won't we do this? We need to do this.
This is the smart thing to do. You know,
what's the right thing to do? And I would
just eventually get like the little,
hey, stand down. We're not doing it. Okay.
You know what I'm going to do,
become an officer and wanna have
to listen to you anymore. So yeah,
I've got, I think I've gotten a couple
stand downs and my time 10 down.
That's an order cause he had,
that's an order that really,
when you think about our,
anyway, when I think about it,
it really does seem like a movie line.
Yeah.
And when the thing is that means that
you have not done a good job as a leader.
If I have to say that's an order,
that means I haven't done
as good a job as a leader.
That means you don't understand the
mission. You don't understand the intent.
You don't understand.
I haven't conveyed it to you properly
and the only way I can get you to listen
to is by saying that's an order pulling
rank. Yeah, pulling rank on you.
That's not a good, not a good
situation. Back to the book.
Never overlook failure to carry one out.
So it's never given unnecessary order.
Okay.
Some people will have to chime in
with their opinions on that one.
Never overlook failure to carry one out.
I'm not sure on that one.
What does that mean to carry one?
That's what I'm saying.
I don't know. It says,
it says never ordered troops to do what?
You're not prepared to do yourself.
Never given unnecessary order.
Never overlook failure to carry one out
to carry out in order to carry one out.
Never overlook failure to carry one out.
I'm not sure what he means by that book.
I'm sure some people will give us
some opinions on that one. Yeah,
on the Facebook you and I release keep
fit yourself and make certain that your
men do to keep your own nerves
under control and study your men's
good
for like when you want to comment. If
you're listening and you want to comment,
you have an opinion on that one.
Put It on the Facebook posts so it can
follow the conversation as opposed to
Twitter, which is 140
characters. You know what I mean?
It's easier to see it on Facebook when
there's a legit question or someone has
some legit big feedback.
If you put it on the thread for
podcasts number 81, when I post it,
that's the place to put in there in the
replies when I can like converse back on
that subject without having to go through
17,000 tweets and then go back and
forth.
So it's all laid out on Facebook.
So it's a good place to have those
little conversations. Twitter,
we have different kinds of
conversations. Sure. Last of all,
remember that success in war depends more
than anything else on the will to win.
Cool. Again, now we've
got Monte saying Morales,
the most important we got Jocko saying
leadership is the most important and you
got brigadier general month sell saying
that the will to win
is the most important.
I'm not going to actually argue
with either one of these guys.
These guys were all uh,
all kinds of experience.
Much more intense than mine.
Speaking of intense
experience more than mine.
There's a guy,
a pseudonym,
meaning a fake name Basil Lisc.
And the guy wrote something called talks
on leadership and the guy's actual name
was Alfred burn and he was a world war
one and World War Two veteran and he was
a military historian and he's got a
little section in here called the being
straight.
There's one trait in the character of
a leader that above all things really
counts and it perhaps counts in war
even more than in peace being straight.
No amount of ability,
knowledge or cunning can ever
make up for not being straight.
Once those under him find
out that a commander is
absolutely straight and all of
his dealings with them and free from the
slightest trade of self interest other
than the self interest of
which we are all guilty.
When striving for victory of
causes we believe to be right,
they will love him as their
leader, trust him, worked for him,
follow him and should the occasion arise,
die for him with the fundamental ability
of the British soldier which comes to
the surface when things
are at their worst.
So being straight with your people,
very important,
very important.
In fact,
perhaps his most important.
Above all.
So now we've got another factor.
That's the most important thing.
Now you're going to hear a
little on leadership from
Field Marshal Lord herring.
Once again,
World War One and World War II veteran,
he also fought in the
second battle of Al Ameen.
He was a wounded,
lost some fingers recovered,
got back to the fight.
So he says about leadership here,
there are some people who believe that
leadership is something which is inborn
or which you acquire
automatically at a public school.
But neither of those things are true.
There are certain fundamental qualities
which affect leadership in which depend
to a very large extent on upbringing
and the moral and spiritual values which
you can learn what you learn in your
family and in your environment as a young
man.
But there was no special way,
nor is there any special caste or class
which has the prerogative of leadership.
There are many forms of leadership.
Political parties have their leaders,
every big organization and industry
or commerce all have their leaders.
And at the other end of the scale,
so do dance bands and so do
gangs of thieves. And smugglers.
There are many qualities that apply
equally to every type of leader,
but you and I are concerned
with one particular type
of leadership to my mind at
the highest type of all and
that is leadership on the
battlefield and I believe
it to be the highest type because it
has to be exercised under conditions of
great difficulty and considerable danger.
I would like to be quiet.
I would like you to be quite clear about
the conditions under which you will
have to exercise leadership.
You will frequently be tired.
You may also be cold and
wet and hungry and thirsty.
You may be dripping with sweat
or you may be freezing with cold.
You won't know precisely what is going on.
You won't know exactly where the enemy is.
You certainly won't know what he is going
to do or what his capabilities are of
doing anything.
You may not know where your own people
are or what they are going to do.
To put it briefly,
you've got to be able to
exercise leadership and
conditions of fatigue and fear,
uncertainty and ignorance
and often in isolation.
That is what makes it extremely difficult
and that is why leadership on the
battlefield calls in my view
for the highest qualities,
many qualities are required in leader.
Different people have different
views about which are more important.
In my opinion, there are five
outstanding mental and physical,
moral and spiritual qualities without
which you cannot hope to be successful and
a good leader on the battlefield.
The first of those qualities is a mental
and physical one and that is fitness,
absolute fitness of mind and body.
So
make sure you're getting your
morning physical training in
physical fitness, mental fitness. Next.
Then I would say you've got
to have complete integrity.
You've got to be honest,
not only with yourselves but with the
menu lead and the people with whom you
work and honesty and an integrity are
things that you cannot compromise with.
You cannot alter.
If you do,
you will lose confidence and
you will not be able to lead.
You must have complete integrity.
So
that's the same thing as being straight.
Yeah.
Not after that.
Not In any next to, sorry. Next after
that. Not In any order of priority,
but this is how I have put
them down deep in my mind.
There is an enduring courage pretty well.
Everyone can be brave for a few minutes.
Most of us can if we
steal ourselves to it.
Take one pledge or make one
decision or incur one risk,
but the sort of courage you must have to
lead on the battlefield is an enduring
courage and one that you will go that
will go on when other people falter.
One that will enable you to do what you
know to be right irrespective of the
danger or the difficulty.
Contrary,
often contrary to the advice
of well meaning friends,
so
gotta have courage.
Next then you must have daring initiative.
Initiative means doing right away
what you might. If you had time,
think of doing a few minutes later.
I like
this.
If you wait for things to happen to you,
they will happen.
All right
and here I am quoting the words of
my predecessor also spoken here.
They will happen to you but they won't
be what you like and they certainly won't
bring you success.
Initiative means seeing at once and
very quickly what needs to be done,
making up your mind to do it and
then seeing it through to the middle,
a bitter end,
so I love that one.
If you wait for things to happen to you,
they certainly will
a little bit more on willpower here,
then you must have undaunted willpower.
The willpower is the motive power.
It is what enables you to make yourself
fit in mind and body to produce in you,
in your heart.
The courage,
the enduring courage that I spoke of to
give you the courage to do your duty and
to make the sacrifice that
may be called from you.
It is the willpower that you to take
the initiative, to make the plan,
to do what is required to see through
and that will power must be undaunted.
It must never allow itself
to be overcome or subdued.
Perhaps the finest example living today
of the power and influence for good of
man. We've undaunted willpower
as our prime minister.
In one of the critical periods of
the last war, he spoke certain words.
I am going to quote you now.
He said,
all the great struggles in history
have been won by superior willpower,
resting victory in the teeth of odds
or upon the narrowest of margins.
It is the willpower that is superior
that can rest victory and the teeth of
odds.
That is the type of willpower that has
got to be developed in a leader on the
battlefield.
Mobilize your will.
Yeah.
Now he talks about some other qualities.
He talks about knowledge.
He talks about judgment.
He talks about Team Spirit's saying,
because you cannot get success
on the battlefield by yourself.
You've got to work with other people,
so obviously as a leader you have
to have that spirit of teamwork
and closing out. He says, there's one
other thing I would like to say to you
as British officers, you will never
have all you want. All you need,
you'll be short of this or that or the
other. Sometimes you will be short of men.
Other Times your equipments are weapons
may not be as good as you think they
ought to be, nor will you have
as many as you would like.
You may be short of ammunition.
You may also be sure to food and water
or other necessary things when these
circumstances arise as they do
often throughout your service,
both in peace and war,
there's only one motto and that is to
make certain that you do the very best you
can with what you got.
Don't belly gate about
what you have not got,
but get on and make certain you do
your utmost with what you have got.
Now, to sum up what I've
tried to say this afternoon,
I would like to put it like this
first, keep fit, absolutely fit.
Then be honest, honest with yourselves,
and honest with those with whom you work.
Then have courage and make
it an enduring courage. Next,
be bold. Be Daring, and
when there is a choice,
take the bold and daring course.
Make the very most of what
you have got and never, never,
never give in.
Yes.
Do what you can with what you've got
until you really liked the whole night.
Yeah, yeah. Sometimes it's
time to start dating me.
All right,
next,
there's a chapter in this book,
which is called discipline,
which makes me very happy.
And again,
I tried to censor myself from not
just doing the entire chapter.
Obviously you can buy this book if
you want to see the whole thing.
There's some great points.
This first one is from field marshal
Earl wave bell who was in the Bueler wars
and he was in World War One and in
World War II he lost his left eye in the
battle of [inaudible].
So we're talking a warrior here
that was went back for service.
Here's what he said about discipline.
Discipline is teaching,
which makes a man do something which he
would not unless he had learnt that it
was the right, the proper,
and the expedient thing to do.
At its best,
it is instilled and maintained
by pride in one's self,
in one's unit,
in one's profession,
only at its worst by fear of punishment.
So he's talking,
we want self discipline. We
don't want impose discipline.
That's what he's saying.
You don't want, I don't want you doing
this because you're scared of me.
If you don't do what I tell you, I'm
going to beat you. That's not what I want.
I want you saying I'm going to
do this because I want to do it.
Here's a little something from Monte
here and we're going to get some
disagreements going. I'm going
to disagree with Monte. Sorry.
Monti wish you were
here to defend yourself.
Okay. On Discipline Monte, the basis of
training must be self-discipline. Cool.
A man must learn to be the master of
himself and to keep in subjection the bad
qualities in his makeup.
I love that self discipline can be
developed by training and such things as
conception of duty, self
control, self respect,
endurance and so on.
We then have collective discipline
and there's no doubt that the initial
training in this subject is
best carried out by drill.
Men must be taught
instinctively to obey orders,
whatever they are.
I do not believe men we'll fight to
voluntarily for a cause without the iron
bonds of discipline.
The best form of discipline
is subordination of self
for the benefit of the
community. So I'm going to
make some comments on those.
Number one,
when you saying that you should obey
orders regardless of what they are,
don't agree. I don't agree with that.
I want my men to question my orders.
I want them to,
if I'm telling you them to do something
that they don't think it's smart,
I want them to question me. I want them
to come up with them a better solution.
That's how we're going to win
the moral thing to write.
Like to obey orders regardless.
Oh yeah. Oh, for sure.
For sure. I want my whole team to be,
hey, if this is the wrong thing to do,
we shouldn't be doing it. Yeah. Next,
the other one he says here is he says
that people won't fight for a cause
without the iron bonds of discipline.
I don't believe that that's true either.
Hmm. And I think if you look
at American history guys,
the, we didn't have the strict level.
Of course there's, there's discipline.
Of course in the military I, there's
imposed discipline in the military.
But the things that people
and all soldiers I have
accomplished without strict
imposed discipline is they've given their
lives over and over and over thousands
and thousands and thousands and hundreds
of thousands of cases where men have
given their lives.
Not because,
not because I said or because the leader
said go into charge this machine gun
nest. That's, that's not why they did it.
They did it because they
believed in the cause.
So I don't agree with that one.
I think that men will fight
voluntarily for our cause.
Okay.
Without the iron balance of discipline.
And you know, when I think they do it,
I think they do it when
that causes freedom.
So when the cause is freedom,
I believe men,
we'll fight without the bonds of
discipline over them. Hmm. And
this idea that the best form of discipline
is the subordination of self for the
benefit of the community. I don't
actually agree with that one either.
I think the best form of discipline
is when there is alignment in the
discipline,
the discipline for the team and the
individual bring success and survival and
freedom and when those things are aligned,
that's when I think you get
the finest form of discipline.
Now he recovers a little bit from
my criticism here. Sure, sure.
And of course to everyone that is
wondering why I'm sort of making fun of
myself.
It's pretty embarrassing to be sitting
here and disagreeing with a guy like
Monte,
so please don't take me the wrong way.
I'm just giving my opinion here that
I'm in no way comparing my military
knowledge with General
Montgomery and he does say this,
the basis of all discipline
is self discipline,
which this is beautiful.
When I agree with that 100% this,
this self discipline may come from within
a person or may be imposed upon him
from without. Don't agree. That'll only
last a little while. Whatever it serves,
its source eight involves the idea
of self control and self restraint.
That is true.
There is,
I think it's called.
Yeah,
situational discipline I think.
Or what does that could,
I could have the expression wrong, but
I think it is situational. Just meaning,
yeah,
like if you're in a certain
situation you'll have,
you'll be really self
disciplined, but once you get
out, you're not, you know, like,
um, I don't know. You ever, you
ever watched what's the big,
there's a show called the biggest loser.
No.
So that's the only people that are having
weight problems. They go on a show,
they get fed certain things and made to
work out and they lose a bunch of weight
and then they win the program and then
when they go back home and they're not
around that impose discipline. Right.
They lose it. Right. That's my point.
My point is that that imposed discipline,
it works.
While you have the input in they,
they're watching you.
What I would prefer is to have someone
that makes out change in their mindset
and develops self discipline right now.
Sometimes you can get that from imposed
discipline and you realize like you get
shown the freedom that it discipline
gives you and then you carry on with it.
Like a lot of people that listen to
the podcast and they've done incredible
things with their lives because we weren't
there to impose discipline on them,
but they recognize themselves. Maybe
they said, okay, you know what,
I'm going to get up for the next
two weeks and gonna get up early.
I'm going to workout, I'm going
to eat healthy. Two weeks go by,
they've lost a little bit of body fat,
they've gained a little bit of
muscle and they feel good. Right?
And all of a sudden they realize the
benefits of discipline and so they changed
their mindset and they become more
disciplined human beings. Yeah.
That's what I like when I don't like is
it all run a bootcamp on you and yell at
you and screaming, but that's another
thing people want me to yell and scream.
I get that. I think once or
twice a day someone will say,
you need to make an alarm clock where
you'd yell and tell us to tell me to get
out of bed.
I said good psychological warfare,
but I'm not going to yell
and psychological warfare
because yelling isn't an
effective tool compared to actually
speaking to someone and letting them
understand why it's important. Yeah.
That's the preferred tool. Occasionally.
Do you got to yell at people
occasionally? Yes. You do. Okay.
Usually not very often though.
Yeah. That's pretty rare,
Huh? But yeah, the yeah,
you're right.
Hub with that situational discipline.
Cause even I think about what's worse.
Somebody yelling at you or someone
whispering, it's you. It's actually worse,
isn't it? Some ways. In a lot of
ways, yeah. To me it's worse. Sure.
Yelling and screaming does,
doesn't know. And it really doesn't
really matter what they're saying either
if he choose yelling or whispering.
Cause like, you know, even if they're
telling you a normal thing like, hey,
I'm here. This is what I want from
the store. I want Avocados, tomatoes,
and you know, some wine. But what
if I whisper it to you? Hey chuck,
come here bro. That my freak
me out. Actually he may give
me something. Yeah. Yeah.
So it did exist. No, no, you
get that. That's the point.
It doesn't really matter what
they're saying with Spring versus,
he definitely has a different
psychological effects for sure.
Cause that's definitely freaks me out.
Hey Jack,
we didn't pick up a bottle of wine.
No, actually I can. I'm leaving.
Yeah, the wine kind of makes
it extra awkward for sure.
All right, so now we get into another
part on discipline right here.
And this is Sir John Four to skew and
what you pay attention to this one because
when we start going sideways,
I have in my mind rather those excellent
but generally unthinking persons who
shrink with horror from the idea of
a man's abdicating his civil rights.
What they say a man must obey
even an unjust command under pain.
It may be of death.
It is monstrous for
purposes of civil life,
it might be monstrous,
but not for the purposes
of implicit obedience,
which is the thing that
matters in the army.
Let there be justice as far
as possible by home means.
But as a general principle,
it is better for an army that an injustice
should be done than that in order
should be disobeyed.
This however,
is an argument that cannot appeal to our,
to our imaginary objector because
he has red, no military history.
So that's just very disturbing.
This whole thing.
And it's really doesn't comply
with anything that I say,
which is I want you to question orders
and if they're not good orders that you
shouldn't obey him. And
he said, no, no, no,
it's better to do something unjust
as long as you are obeying orders.
And I get a little bit of research
about John Four to skew and you know,
obviously I don't agree with this. And
actually in the new version of the book,
He,
the,
the guy that writes the forward to the
new version of this specifically calls
out John Four to skew and says,
we removed him the him,
these were gone from the book.
And what I found out about him was yes,
he was in the army,
he was a major in the army. Um, but
I don't think he was in any combat.
And what I do know is that he was the
royal librarian from 1905 until 1926 and
he died in 1923 so he
didn't go to World War One.
All these other guys are World War One,
World War II veterans.
He was the like the Royal Librarian.
And it's interesting when he says
because he has red, no military.
He hasn't said cause he's never been
in combat before. He says he's ready.
The person that would object to this
has never read military history.
Well Yeah Uri. Yeah, he's going
with the theory. Yeah. And,
and if you want to take this
and stretch it out more broadly,
this attitude, you know,
I hate World War One.
I hate world war one because it was so
based on obedience and you are going to
charge,
we're going to charge this trench.
All 7,000 of us are going
to charge tomorrow morning
at zero six 30 where to go
over the top.
We're going to get mowed down by machine
guns and then the people are going to
follow us. And do the same thing. And
they, they've guys were so obedient
and brave and just selfless to do that.
But this attitude is what made that
war so devastating because no one said,
hey, wait a second. This
doesn't seem smart to me. Yeah,
I just watched, you know, two, three,
four battalions are two, three,
four regiments get mowed down and now
you're telling me I'm going to do the same
thing tomorrow with my men?
No,
I want you to question my orders.
I want you to say no.
If I'm making you do something that
doesn't make sense, I want you to say no.
And if I can't explain it
to you in a logical way,
then I should rethink what
I'm saying to you. Hmm.
So Mr. John Ford Askew,
we're going to have to say that we've got
to change our opinion on, on obedience.
And there are more important
things than obedience in a team,
in a military team and
in the business world.
Here's another piece from this is
going back to General Williams slim.
Any army without discipline as no more
than a mob alternating between frightened
sheep and beasts of prey discipline as
the British soldiers demonstrated in
peace and war is the old
Christian virtue of unselfishness,
of standing by your neighbor,
your comrade.
It is the sacrifice of a man's
comfort, inclination, safety,
even life for others,
for something greater than himself.
It is the refusal to be the weak link
in the chain that snaps under under
strain, and this is a great
little story here. One paragraph
back to the book.
Once from the safety of
a well dug command post,
I looked down on a battery of our
artillery inaction in the African Bush.
It was firing at five
rounds per gun per minute,
and ideally I the
nearest gun in that area.
The enemy unfortunately had complete
local air supremacy and guns,
unless engaged in some vital tasks,
were ordered to remain silent
whenever hostile aircraft appeared
gradually dominating all other sounds
came the dull drone of bombers flying low.
But the guns went on firing five
rounds per gun per minute for they were
supporting an infantry attack
covered move. By the way,
the first stick of bombs
fell around the gun.
I was watching some of his crew were hit.
The dry brush roared into flame,
which spread instantly to the
camouflage nets over the gun.
It vanished from my site
and smoke and flame.
Yet from the very midst of that inferno
at the exact intervals came the flash
and thud of the firing gun.
Five rounds per minute per gun,
never falter,
never a second out,
no weak link there.
The discipline held.
That's pretty awesome
sections here talking about
duty and service and we're
going to first start with
Colonel George Henderson,
a British officer
who fought in Egypt and
at the battle of Kasasa
and he fought in the
bueler awards as well,
and he talks about Waterloo.
Here we go. Back to the book.
No incident is more familiar
in our military history.
Then the stubborn resistance of
the British line at Waterloo truth.
The long hours of the mid Summer Day,
silent and immovable squares and
squadrons stood in the trampled corn,
harassed by an almost incessant fire
of candidate and musketry to which they
were forbidden to make reply.
Not a moment,
but heard some cry of agony.
but some comrade fell head
long into the furrows.
Yet as bullets of the skirmishers hailed
around them and the great shot tore
through the tight packed ranks,
the word was passed quietly
close in on the center men and
as the sun near its setting,
the regiments still shoulder to shoulder
stood fast upon the ground they had
held at noon.
The spectacle is characteristic
in good fortune and in ill.
It is rare indeed that a British
regimen does not hold together and this
indestructible cohesion,
best of all qualities that an armed
body can possess is based not merely on
hereditary resolution,
but on mutual confidence
and mutual respect.
The man and the ranks has
implicit faith in his officer,
the officer,
and almost unbounded belief in the
valor and discipline of his men.
And that I've talked about this and
people want to know what makes the seal
teams do well.
The thing that makes the seal teams do
well is the bond that holds them together.
And that bond is so strong
that it's unbreakable.
And that's why seals do well in
combat because we have a bond that is
unbreakable, stronger than anything
that's going to get thrown at us.
The Brotherhood is going to stand.
Hey,
I'm gonna close this book
out with two more quotes.
And speaking of Waterloo,
this one is from Wellington
and this is a very simple quote.
He said,
my rule was always to do the
business of the day in the day.
And I,
I was reading this book the other day
and I actually posted something about it,
but I, I, I was, I didn't realize
I was thinking about this,
but we have a saying in the seal teams
plan your dive and dive your plan is the
saying. So when you're, when you're
doing a combat swimmer attack,
which is when you're on a rebreather and
you're diving underwater and what are,
if you've never dove before,
if you don't understand this,
it's very hard to comprehend
what combat swimmer is like.
But I'll give you a real quick brief.
When you're doing a combat
dive on a rebreather,
you basically can't see
anything. It's nighttime. Hmm.
You're down at 10 1215 feet underwater.
It's black, you can't see anything.
There's no like fish swimming around.
There's no sea life to look at.
There's no core reef. It's black,
you can't see anything.
The only thing you can actually see
is something called an attack board,
which would attack board. Sounds really
cool. But let me tell you what it is.
It's a piece of plastic.
He used to be wood that
has on it a depth gauge,
a compass and a watch to time.
And so you put little tiny chem lights,
little glowing chem lights,
and you're actually tape them up so that
they're barely emitting any light at
all. And you put one by the
Stopwatch, one by the compass.
And one by the depth gauge and when you're
underwater. So you have those things,
they're basically strapped onto this board
that you hold. Uh, I dunno, it's like,
like the,
about the size of a piece of paper,
eight and a half by 11 piece of paper.
That's about how big this board isn't
on it. You've got your depth gauge,
your compass and your stopwatch,
and you can barely see them.
They're glowing very faintly.
And when you're underwater,
that's all you can see. It's just
that you can't see anything else.
Occasionally you'll get like some
weird abstract light from the moon or
something. But even that's rare
because you're down underwater.
And if you've ever been in water with
low visibility sometimes that sometimes
it's actually hard to see the attack board
that's two feet in front of your face.
So then what you're doing is
you're looking at that compass,
you're looking at that depth gauge and
you're looking at the stopwatch and you
have preplanned legs that you're going on.
You're going to go this long,
this, this bearing, this long,
this depth for this time.
And when I say it.
So you're kicking looking at this
board for an hour and 17 minutes,
then you're going to make a 90 degree
turn and you're going to go for another 48
minutes,
and then you're gonna make a right turn
for 12 minutes and you're going to hit
your target. Then you're gonna turn
around and do some other route back out.
As long as you can stay underwater and
standard water that eventually you run
out of oxygen, you come to the t the
surface and you swim the rest of the way.
Do your extract
any visions of the glory and
the the fun of being a seal.
This is not,
it's work and it's hard work and you
have to concentrate the whole time and
you've got to make sure you
don't go too shallow or too deep.
If you go too shallow, you'll
be seen. If you go too deep,
you're going to go off the dive tables
that you're allowed to be on oxygen for
us. So you got to focus the
whole time. And by the way,
you're in this pair and
your buddy that's with you,
he's even more miserable than you are
because he has no idea what's going on.
He's just trying to keep up with
you because for some reason,
the way you dive for the way you put
your body, when you have the tack board,
you can swim a little bit faster than
the guy that's looking around and making
sure that you're not going to hit
anything and making sure you're not.
So there's only one tack boards. There's
a one attack board for prepare. Okay.
Sometimes we would make to make a smaller
attack board just because it was so
much more efficient to fly with them.
But you can't fly you if
you're the buddy you're,
you can't be just looking
at the tack board.
You have to look around a tack board.
The attack board, that's what we call it,
the attack board.
So with all that,
the reason I'm telling you all this
is that when you're underwater,
it's really easy to get
confused and turned around
and sometimes you go over big
pieces of metal that are in the water.
And your compass starts to
like wander around and you're,
you can't communicate with your buddy.
No. That's what it sounds like you've got.
So we,
you know,
we have squeezed signals and sometimes
we'd carry a grease pens to write,
but it's never, there's no real
effective way to communicate underwater.
So you're just in this dark,
just cold delined situation.
Four, three, two, three,
four hours at a time.
And the saying is that we had is plan
your dive and dive your plan because if
you and I go under water and then we
start trying to adjust things while we're
underwater and we just,
we think we're going to do something
different once we go. First of all,
you and I are going to be thinking two
different things and it's going to be a
disaster.
So we,
we plan our dive and dive our plan and
that's reminded me of this statement.
Do the business of the day in the day,
right?
Get done what you say you're going to
get done. Do it. And how simple as that.
And it's like dive your plan. And
what I said the other day, I said,
plan what you're going to do and then
do what you planned. That's real simple.
And,
and think about how far you're going to
think of where you will be in two weeks
if every day you plan what you're gonna
do and then you do what your plan. Yeah.
It's, it's amazing. Yeah.
It seems so, say that, that,
that was what we were talking about a few
weeks ago where it's like distractions.
That's the thing, you know, there's like
just industries of distractions. Yeah,
for sure.
You never wake up.
I was explaining to my eight year old
daughter the other day that they design,
cause he was playing a
game on iPad. I said, oh,
what are you learning from that? And
she said, what do you mean? I said,
oh are you learning anything
from that? And she said, well I,
you have to get these
rings. And I said, oh,
so you're not learning anything from that?
And she said, I don't, I don't. I said,
you know what they do? They make that
game to make you want to play it more.
There's no, there's no end to the games
to handle it. They just want you to play.
That can keep clicking on
that. That's there, you know?
And of course I'm just being
a total jerk. I'm like, yeah,
look at how we look at how well it works.
Look at you. See you can't put it down.
Look at you.
You look at you holding onto this thing
and she doesn't fall for this anymore.
When she was younger,
I used to go up and and press her head
as if her head was getting softer and I'd
look at her like, Oh man, how long
have you been on this? For instance?
I don't know.
And it's a,
I think if you stopped now your brain
might hardened back up eventually.
I do the same thing with,
with her. Oh, her muscles.
Like you shouldn't be eating like chips,
just too many chips. There's like,
oh your muscles are getting like all
soft right now. Maria, she's young.
She's four. So it works. It still
works. But they do, they plan,
they plan these things so
that they addicted. Yeah.
Dick those iPad once there is no, well,
everything is designed that, right, right.
You talk about the Facebook
app that shows the little thing
that shows,
oh yeah,
like you're going to mess alert and
this might be the message that I've been
waiting for it variable reward. It
might not be, so that's the thing.
That's if you know, guaranteed it
what it's going to be consistently.
It's less addictive. It's called variable
rewards. Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
But you, everyone in their mind
is thinking this might be, ah,
this place might be the big one.
I'm getting contacted by,
by tenacious d. They saw my
tweet. They're getting back at me.
They're going to come on the podcast.
She's tenacious.
D is Jack Black and Kyle gas. Oh, right,
right. Was that a movie? It's a band.
Okay. From a movie. They
have been in a movie. Yes.
And they black Jack Black?
No,
that's a second or not. And as a
musician. Okay. Gotcha. School of rock.
That's a great shot of how, that's
not a movie that's Jack Black. No, no.
He is an actor. Like I said, in addition
to being a board member who, okay. Gotcha.
Cool. Why don't we just
talk about, oh yeah,
because I think in all of this might
be the tweet that I was waiting for it,
right.
From tenacious d.
So I gotta check my Twitter 47
times a minute. No, not happening.
You can't, you don't have a tweet
from tenacious d that's not there.
They didn't treat you.
So don't check your Twitter.
Go and do something productive. Yeah. So,
and that's when you're already distracted.
So basically the point was,
you know,
do your plot or plan your day or
do you know and do the plan, right?
Because no one plan your day and
do what you plan. Yeah, that's it.
So yeah, no one plans to work.
What's really jacked up ease.
If you actually took what you did in a
day and you wrote it down and planned it,
I bet you could get it done in so
much last time. Like right now,
I've got a lot of stuff going on right
now and I'm doing things that normally
take me two hours.
I'm doing in 46 minutes.
Same quality getting after it,
right?
But you got to put a little suspense
date on something and say, us do here.
You've got to get it done. And then
you just sit down and make it happen.
That's what you need to do it. It's
one of those simple, but Anita,
these easy things. But this is why
it's so you would you put in a way,
you put these kind of parameters on
what you're going to do and if like if,
okay, I'm making a plan and I'm sticking
to the plan, right? That's what I'm doing.
So I plan to do x, Y, Z. Excellent. You
know, all these things. So basically,
right when you say, okay, here's the plan,
you outline it. If it's not in the plan,
you just don't do it.
It's so, so distractions.
No one plans like, Hey, tomorrow I'm
going to just eat like crap tomorrow.
That's the plan. That's
never the plan, you know?
But if you don't have any plan or nothing,
sure.
You allow those things to come
in. So was fear like, okay,
tomorrow and you're not
going to plan the whole day.
You're not combined every meal
you're going to. If you did,
you'd be real effective.
You'd stay on locked. Right.
Got so much in the meal prep
the night before. Exactly.
When you go through those phases where
you're cooking seven chicken breasts and
you're just ready, you got
everything laid out, there you go.
It's real easy that people do that and it
works. Yes sir. Yeah, exactly right. So,
and is it realistic and really when
you think about it kind of is if you're
committed to it. Well what's crazy
is is it takes more work upfront.
How long does it take to prepare all
your meals for the week? And by the way,
I don't do this,
but how long I've done it before?
How long does it take to prepare meals?
It takes you two hours,
two hours and 20 minutes, let's
say at a time. By the way,
you get done preparing those and
you save time in the week, right?
Cause now you're not sitting around
redeploying your pots and pans,
redeploying your stove setting,
all that other stuff.
You actually are going to save time if
you plan your day and then you do your
plan. Yeah. And think about this, if
you use a meal prep example where,
okay,
you don't typically,
we don't plan our every meal for
a week two, we just don't do that.
But when you do the meal
prep planning situation,
you're saying we meaning human beings
in general, the typical person.
So that's a good example. So
when you do that now, boom,
that your meals,
uh,
an element of your life that typically
isn't quote unquote planned is now
planned. So now they're,
those parameters are sick.
So anything outside of
those parameters do,
you just don't really think
about it as much, you know?
And when they kind of enter you,
it's real obvious like, hey,
that's not part of this plan. What
the hell? You know, it's like,
it's more of a red flag,
but if you don't plan it,
they come in and it's
kind of like whatever.
There was no parameters
there anyway in my head.
So that goes for everything you can do.
So just like how you're saying, yeah,
I have a lot of stuff. So you plan, okay,
I'm going to do this here and do this now,
do this at this time,
finish it by this time, all this
stuff, those parameters are set.
So the distractions I've
way harder tend to get it.
So in everyday life you can make some
ambiguous goal. Hey, I want to eat better.
No plan. By the way, just
it's an ambiguous goal.
There's those parameters on there.
So you take one misstep, you,
you know you were at the stop
light for longer than you expected,
and now you're late for this. Now I'm
pressed for time. There's a Mcdonald's,
right? And it'll just sneak right in.
But if you've got those parameters,
then you'd be at Mcdonald's. No, not
part of my plan right now. My plan,
I got to do, got to execute
it. And another thing,
if you're going to plan your day,
you should actually plan to have
time in there that has nothing
in it, right? So you should,
you should plan to have a
half an hour where you're,
where you're going to address
problems. Right. Okay.
So that way a problems because they're
going to come up, I mean you gotta,
you gotta have your free time and by free,
I mean free to go make other things
happen and adjust and make things good.
But what you shouldn't do is say,
because I'll tell you there's some
things that I have a really hard time,
like with the podcast,
I'll
keep preparing the podcast. I'll just
kill you're carrying it. Like I'll just,
I know I did go beyond that because
there's another story that ties into
something else and I'm going to go
pull out another book. And by the way,
I got to run,
I don't have time to get it from Amazon,
so I'm going to go to the library,
you know what I mean?
You go down where I could prepare for a
podcast forever and not be ready for it.
And so I have to put my own
self and check and say, okay,
draw the line on this level
of depth on this thing.
Now I might make a footnote and I've kind
of cool category now on my computer of
that's you know,
tangents where I,
where I opened a tangent and I
didn't close it on the podcast.
So now we're going to be able to
enter them at a different time when,
when time allows, because I can
get focused on that one subject.
So that's pretty cool.
But it takes discipline to do that
because otherwise I would just go down,
every rabbit hole is opened up and you
take a book like this and there's so many
rabbit holes and there it's almost
impossible to stay out of them.
Gets kind of ridiculous. Yeah. In a way.
So my point is
plan your day and then execute your plan.
If you do that,
it's going to make a huge
difference in your life.
And what's cool did you look
up, you look up in a month,
two months,
three months,
the amount of stuff that you've
gotten done as ridiculous.
And I'll tell you one of the ways that
I do do that myself as I just put tasked
myself with the, I say I'm going to do
things and then would have to do them.
Yeah, they are great. That Pie, if let's
say with this podcast, a good example,
we do this podcast once a week.
We've held the line really well on that.
If we didn't, if we said, you know what,
let's just put the podcast
out when we put it out.
If that was the mindset we had from
the beginning, we would probably,
I'm going to guess that we would have
less than half of the podcasts would have
been put out. That's my guess because
we noticed said, you know what?
Hey I got to train this week and I'm
going to miss that and I haven't read the
book that I was going to read
so cause right now bro, the, Oh,
I've got 15 minutes, that little half
hour of my schedule where I have nothing,
guess what I'm doing in that half an hour
I'm doing 22 minutes worth of reading
of a book that's coming up.
That's what I'm doing.
If we didn't have the
discipline structure in place,
that probably wouldn't be happening.
Yeah.
That probably wouldn't be
happy we'd be going to,
you know what little time went by.
Hey Bro. Yeah, let's, let's, let's,
let's give this week of miss it
so much easier. You know what?
I was going to go hang out today and
don't really want to do this today. No,
we're doing it. We, we signed
up for it. Yeah, totally. Now,
could it get to a point where we say,
you know what,
every two weeks we've
mentioned that before.
People didn't like that idea.
Yeah. Wealth didn't like that idea.
I didn't like that. I knew better. You
know why? Cause I liked that discipline.
Yeah. Why would you know
why? Because I'm basically,
I'm basically confining myself to doing
something productive as opposed to
watching youtube videos about cats
because there's some great youtube videos,
right?
There's some good youtube videos,
but there's also a lot of them are not
good and you're not getting anything out
of them. Yeah. And Man,
the ones that they rack up for you
when you've just got done watching one,
the ones that they rack up for you all,
every single one of them,
what did they rack up?
I think they rack up for on top and
four on bottom on your little screen.
And every one of 'em is,
is like a clickbait. Right?
Every one of them is a click
clickbait. It's crazy. Yeah. It's,
they do the obvious.
They are brilliant. Yeah.
Because it has a lot to do with everything
that you've, you've walked for sure.
So yeah, it's going to be the neck. The
video is always just like, it's a month,
90% relevant to what you specifically
one right there. And that is why.
That is why you got to get angry at the,
you know, you know, you have that, uh,
you know how you have that,
that way that you overcame your
anger, my anger management. Right.
But you read that it was
like you had low self esteem.
That's why you're getting
mad. Well, when you get that,
when you get that next rack of
youtube videos staring at you,
you should be getting pissed because
you know what they're trying to do.
They're trying to get you to try to take
your time away from you. And by the way,
they're making money from it. When you
click that next thing they're making,
they're making money from what
you're doing. And so they've,
they've set this system up to
make you click that thing. Yeah.
So you're a mark is what you want.
All you are mark [inaudible] look at
you falling for it every single day.
That's how I quit drinking too, by
the way. That is legit. Like, Oh,
I'm falling for a trick that
my brain is playing on me.
I ain't falling for that trick and falling
for that trick. That, and like I said,
it's hard to,
because it's mixed in with
positive stuff on youtube.
They're really good
quality stuff on Youtube.
There's some great knowledge you
can gain from Youtube for sure.
And if you're good at justifying
things, yeah, that's true too.
It's a really scary,
but my point is I don't want us to sit
here and bag on youtube because it's an
incredible source of information
if you keep it informational,
but it's real easy to get sideways on
that and they somehow know they can attach
like watching a street fight too. Cause
I watched street fights or I watch, uh,
you know, a UFC fight or I'll watch
a clip or I'll watch a submission.
They know how to drag you in to like those
click bait titles of the guy fighting
the kangaroo. Yeah, man
versus kangaroo. Unbelievable.
Right. And of course you're
thinking yourself, okay,
well what would I do if I didn't fight
her kangaroo? I live in America, man.
I'm not fighting any Kangaroos, but
somehow I've got to click on that video.
Such garbage. So good job. Youtube.
And I'm
not going to be a soccer over
here. Nope, not it will be a mark.
Give yourself a limit. Yeah,
see and that goes back to what,
give yourself like a clique
limit on those things. Yeah.
Or just set your plan right. Give
yourself those parameters. Right.
You won't even me thinking
about it right now. It really,
after you kind of explained it there,
it really puts it into perspective
and all the things he ever,
I mean you're different than I think.
I think a lot of people where sometimes
people only make plans if like they have
important stuff. Something
that's important. I got
work stuff where I got it,
I got this to do list.
There's like 10 things on the list,
which actually seems like a pretty big
to do lists. If you think 10 in one day,
you know how many things you do in a
day that you can get distracted from.
A lot of them. Yeah, more than 10 it's
like a lot and that got everything.
Everything from like what the day
you wake up or not the day, but the,
the time you wake up, what you eat
every single time, by the way. Well,
the TV you watch or don't watch like
it's every, every second of the day.
If it had a parameter on it,
oh man.
You'd be just laser focus on all your
goals instead of these ambiguous lose
weight or I want to, I need
to, I dunno. Xyz more. Yeah.
And I'll tell you another thing that the
plan doesn't take that much time to put
together. Yeah. And how you said it's,
it'll end up saving you time. Oh for sure.
We don't end up in one way or another.
We'll 10 minutes that you spend planning
the next day we'll save you four hours.
You can usually get done everything you
have to get done in like a half the time.
Half the time. It's crazy. And it's
weird too because I had no thought there.
I don't want to make it
sound like there's some,
some people that are really busy.
Yeah. But I had a single mom,
she's got two, three kids.
She's got two, three jobs.
She doesn't, you know what? She's
listened this conversation going. Yeah,
no kidding. Okay. Youtube.
Yeah. She's in the game.
24 seven not choosing the game.
20 cause she's warm. She sleeps.
She's keeping it together.
Yeah. And when you say there's
two things to that, yeah. There are busy
people. You know how those get those,
like the single moms or the single dads,
they get kind of like what I just said.
They are in a situation,
they have no choice and they get after it.
I have no choice and they
get after they were like, oh,
I'm going to get this done. They got
their frame. They're looking at their kid,
they're looking at their three year old
kid that that three year old kid has
nothing without that mom getting on the
grind and go into the the restaurant and
working as a waitress or whatever
or she's working her job,
whatever she's doing. Yeah. Just putting
it together knows exactly Tuesday,
three weeks from now I'm at four 46
she knows where she's going to be.
She knows exactly where me, I
mean I don't come on, you know,
compared to the average person
we don't know. And then Kimberly
average was it. You did it right.
You're not even like 100% sure which could
be doing in an hour because you know,
cruising could interlude at any time
and you might just be cruising is a very
ambiguous activity.
The but then go to the other side of
the spectrum of busy people. I mean,
they're busy because they don't plan
enough. It's definitely true. Yeah.
I'm so busy all the time. Meanwhile,
no, no productivity, you know,
or very little limited, limited, true.
Plan your day. Execute
your plan. All right, last
little quote from this.
This is Frederick the great,
the battle of calling in 1757 and
there were some troops that were,
I read a couple of different versions.
Again, speaking of rabbit holes,
we start going down these rabbit holes.
I read two different versions of this.
There was either troops that
were hesitating to attack
or there were troops that
were actually retreating
and to these troops.
Frederick the great said,
dogs would you live forever
and another way that was translated
was you curse it rascals.
Would you live forever? And
who is he saying? This student,
he's saying that to his own troops that
are leaving either either hesitating to
attack, right or they're or they're
retreating and he's saying dogs. Yeah,
Conan the barbarian. No.
Would you live forever?
No. Is that what you're looking for? To
live forever? Yeah. No, you shouldn't be.
Yeah.
And you know, I think that's a
good way to still wrap up that book
because like we said,
those two quotes always do the
business of the day in the day.
So plan where you do
and do what you plan and
dogs.
You curse it rascals.
Would you live forever?
Let me answer that for you.
No you won't.
And we're here talking about a book.
We're talking about a book today and we
talk about leadership and that's awesome.
But you've got to start
by leading yourself
by doing what you say you will do.
That's integrity,
personal integrity.
When you say that you're going to do
something that they've talked about being
straight today,
I talked about personal integrity.
That starts with yourself by doing what
you actually say you are going to do by
not hesitating and waiting.
Get a lead yourself.
So
yeah,
get moving.
Don't wait.
Do what you plan and do it today
because you don't get to live forever
and the clock is ticking
and I think that's all I've
got for tonight and echo
since we are not hesitating
right now.
If you could without hesitation to please
explain to people how they might be
able to support
this podcast if they weren't too sure.
Of course,
because we don't want to live forever.
I guess that doesn't mean
actually Conan the
barbarian didn't say that.
He didn't say he didn't say much in
Conan the barbarian as a few lines,
but not that much.
His girlfriend,
girl, that ends up being his girlfriend.
Then she dies later, but whatever.
She says,
tell me the whole time
when they hesitate or when they're
about to do something nuts. She says,
do you want to live forever? Then they
just charge. Oh, okay. Well there you go.
A couple she she gets. Exactly.
Yeah. That's the exact usage. Anyway,
speaking of not hesitating,
so kettle bells I'm talking about on it,
but this is kind of is relevant.
Reminded me, I kind of mentioned it
earlier before we started recording, so
I hear good things, right?
Kettlebells and I'm a little familiar,
I'll incorporate them here and there,
but you know,
I'm just here more and more so I'm like,
Hey, I'm going to make this part of the,
you know, the routine. The program.
Yeah. You do kettle bells obviously. Yes.
Do you, how much dumbbell
stuff Dee do like dumbbells.
I actually don't use a lot of weight
belts. Big Dumb Bell Guy. Yeah,
like even like bench, right man,
when was the last time I bench?
Like people will say, hey, how much can
you bench? I don't know man. Not Enough.
That's my answer. It's a long time
ago. Anyway, back to the countable,
so starting kettle bells,
but I got him, you know, he'd learned
the tip. Be careful with kettlebells.
If you're doing the kettle bells, you know
how they say yes, start off light. This,
I'd say with kettlebells more so than it,
because when you throw a Kelly that thing,
it's not like a dumbbell is like you
grab a Dumbbell, it has a perfect handle.
Each side of the dumbbells,
perfectly balanced, same exact way,
but kettle bell has a handle that
it's on the thing. It'll flip around,
it'll break your Libra, you can break
your hand or when you're swinging them,
you know the one that you go, I
don't know all the terms, sorry,
but the one you grab it
with a two kettlebells,
the basic one between your legs,
Brown.
I'm like swinging it and
I'm like, Bro, what if this,
what if my balance was off or I dunno,
whatever, and the Kettlebell hit my shin.
You'd be a lot of pain.
It can break your Shin if you don't,
even if it had like a 62 pound
kettlebell you and break your shit.
Be careful with that.
Anyway,
so to make things actually,
technically they're not
what I got the Onnit ones,
the Werewolf and the chimp and all that.
And you think when you compare
them to the regular kettlebells,
the kettle bells around,
right. The regular ones. And
so you'd think, oh, you know,
the design and once with a werewolf,
they might be kind of awkward cause
they're not like perfectly uniform.
But guess what? The balanced
when they make them. Yeah.
So they're just as safe.
But be careful. Um, I'm,
I'm explaining the new,
uh,
emergence of kettle bells in my
workout. Yeah. And you like him?
I like him a lot and the point
is don't hesitate. Right.
Cause you know how you
know, he's like, yeah,
I need to do more kettlebells and big
and big ewas goal. That's what it is.
No parameters. But I was like, you know
what? Today's the day I'm going to do,
I'm going to, this is going to be the
workout. My workout was, you want numbers,
I'll give you numbers.
So what I did, metcon,
kettle bells, the Werewolf. So those are
62 pounds each ad to the double boom.
So, uh, Dee Dee, I don't know if this is
an actual kettle bill official movement.
I think it is. You go, it's
like a kettle bell swing.
Two of them outside of the hips,
narrow stance up to clean,
clean it,
right. And then press and press it right.
And then back down slot boom, boom. Okay.
Nebraska.
Yes.
So I do five reps and then
five burpees walk in a circle.
35 seconds. All right. Five reps again.
So I do that six times.
Took like, I don't know,
eight minutes, eight and a
half minutes. That was a mess.
So same as my other Macron bolt with the
kettle bells and this kind of the squat
probably. It's weird. I used
to do that with a bar. It's,
there's a lot of little muscles in
there that makes kettlebells good.
Is that the one stable?
They're less stable than a bar
bell and they move awkwardly. Yeah.
So you have to use more energy and more
strength to keep them under control.
So it's working some muscles that
you're not used to it most likely. Yeah.
And you're, it's, it's interesting
because you're using, like,
you can get into this kind of,
it's not weird,
but this flow of like,
you don't,
like when it swings down, it's not
like, oh, it doesn't jerk you down.
It will if you're not ready for it.
But if you kind of know after you
get used to it, it just flows.
It's like this almost no impact
via kettle bells are good. Yeah.
So do that anyway. Where would
you get your kettle bells from?
I get my kettle bells from on it.
I only get the corns actually
afterwards and I had a picture.
I was going to post it online
too, but I was thinking, yeah,
you want to feel it was less about
that at that point, you know? Um,
but I, again, the Werewolf ones,
so in Joe Rogan on one of the videos
on there, he kind of mentioned this,
he's like,
I like this one because it's like,
I think it was like the gorilla
or something like that. He's like,
it looks at you and it's like
it wants to do. He says, yeah,
he says that the grill looks like
he wants to bite your dick off.
That's what he says. Something along
this line. But he has a good point.
Like those kettle bells, the
bells when you're like, man,
I really don't want to do this. And then
they're just looking at you, you know,
and you're like, Dang, you walk away,
you come back and you look at it and
it's still looking at you with the same
expression because it's, you know,
Kettlebell, cause it's an inanimate object
and saying it helps. Yeah. You know, cause
you get into the workout, you know? Yeah.
You know, especially like how you, you're
like, it's a challenge every time. Anyway.
Do that. All right on it. Support Right.
audit.com/jocko 10% off kettle bells.
Alpha brain. Strong bone.
Yeah. Krill oil. Big Time.
Shroom tech. Yeah. So with the Krill oil,
mine didn't come in yet. I slacked it,
went to wine. It didn't come in yet.
And I'm kind of, it's weird. I'm slowly
started. I'm not messed up. I'm not,
but I'm slowly starting to, yeah, I
think so. Huh. Actually want to go.
You don't want to let it get
out of your system completely.
That's not good enough. Then they
got to reincorporate into it. Yeah.
I think it takes about six days.
Yeah. In Mike Case, it took really,
it took I think five when I start
to be like all this different.
I think it comes in today nonetheless.
Krill oil,
the best Krill oil straight
up is from on it, so yeah,
on it.com/jocko 10% off. If you want
that 10% off go slash Jocko at. Yeah.
It's a good way to support yourself,
podcasts and get after it
more efficiently. Also,
if you want to check out this book,
serve to lead,
oh,
we'll have it posted on the website.
It takes you to Amazon.
Grab these books from there.
You Click through the website that
supports the podcast really good.
Whether you buy buying these books, any
book we didn't Musashi last week. No,
we did book of five rings
last week or Musashi.
The novel will be covered
in podcast 100 yeah.
If you are, we are going to talk
about the whole book. It's a novel,
so it's going to be spoilers.
So if you want to listen to that podcast,
you got to read that book now.
It's a thousand pages long.
It's freaking long.
Yeah,
so get the book now so that you can get
the satisfaction of the book because it
has the most epic ending. It's one of
the most epic endings of any books. Yeah,
and it's on the DOCO, podcast.com
website books, Jocko, podcasts, books.
They're all on there. Also, the one you
mentioned it today, one called mind games.
The book that I read, Oh, you
put that on there? I didn't yet.
The author is Michael Powell, and
here's the thing, it's not like it's,
it's not like a typical book where
it's like talks about anger management.
It's not that it's,
it's literally like there's little games
like mind brain exercises in there,
you know, it's just everything
and they're really short chapters.
They're just little things in that one
chapter happened to be about dealing with
anger. Anyway, Michael Powell is the
author on though. That was a good,
I'll put it on there though. Legit.
So, yeah. Anyway, Amazon Click through.
Basically you clicked through
there. Boom. Takes Amazon. It's a,
it's a little support thing,
you know, small action,
big reaction or if you do other
shopping on their duct tape,
duct tape if you will. So
yeah. Any shopping really.
But you know, these books,
that's a good, that's a real relevant
one. I think that people, um, you know,
they do want to, to grab these books
and boom, they're on their offer.
I'm also subscribe to the podcast if
you haven't already. Itunes, stitcher,
Google play, whichever one you prefer.
I think iTunes is the most popular, but
I see significant references to
Google play in general society,
you know, also a lot of
temperature. Stitcher. Yeah.
Do you know how like a lot of times
people, they don't want to go mainstream,
you know? Oh yeah. It's like, like
they like to keep it old school.
Hard underground. Yeah. You
know, it makes sense. You know,
what's the old saying? Don't go with their
herd or path less traveled, you know,
one of those, all those same, same deal,
same deal. So I get it. Google play.
But good news is we're on all of
them. Boom. Choose your your avenue.
Also Youtube.
Subscribe to our Youtube Channel.
We do have you youtube
channel talk about every week,
but it not only does it have a video
version of this podcast has excerpts and
deluxe serps or do those
excerpts that you have enhanced.
We'll just say enhanced depth
excerpts also. You know what man,
I have this other idea. You know what
I'm going to do? I'm to make little,
we'll just say other little videos too.
That's what I'm going to stick.
Bad add value,
so to speak like that.
Well the video is a very compelling
form of interaction with people.
That's why,
that's why Youtube,
I think youtube is like the most
search to website, bigger than,
it's more searched than Google.
Maybe I'm wrong, but it's up there.
If it's not number one, it's number
two. So if you want to learn something,
people immediately, yes,
I searched youtube. Yeah,
that's what I guess what you remember the
other day we talked about youtube red.
Yeah, I got youtube red. Oh, I'll buy
because the ads, the ads is one thing,
but also because you can listen to
music without it being on the screen.
It plays in the background like iTunes
that is that the main reason now I can
get any album that,
cause a lot of the music is a lot of
music that I listened to isn't on iTunes
because it's old school. It's
hardcore. It's underground,
like literally not on there,
but the youtube videos up there crazy.
It's a youtube video will be on there
from some random hardcore band from New
York, upstate New York and
they're there. They're there.
One album that they made,
the one e p five songs long that
came out in 1987 it'll be on youtube.
It's not anywhere near iTunes. It's on
it and you can play it, which is awesome.
Makes Sense.
I guess they youtube red sometimes they'll
put or not something to all the time.
Do you have youtube red? No. No,
because the main selling point problem
is that the albums without tracks,
just Fyi, you like albums with tracks.
These are alphabetic without tracks.
Well typically I don't listen to Youtube
for the music situation where I'd go to,
if you have red you will change that.
Maybe I mean red, they push it with hey,
no ads and then I'm like
cool, no ads. But man,
I'm not that quick to
jump on the no Ed's thing.
There had been plenty of times
for a lot of times with movies,
but the ads that play,
I all like it'll be for me
directly for me. Like Dang,
this ad is helping me in a way.
Sometimes the ultimate youtube
person battling maybe a quick,
the next video I'm going to enjoy the
advertisement. The Tai Lopez adds a lot,
you know that is right. Tai Lopez,
he's a um, he's super smart guy.
He's actually one of the reasons
why like I started reading a lot,
like one of the reasons and so smart
guy pled his ads are all over youtube,
but I know it's my fault because it's
relevant to what I watch apparently.
You know how they do that. So it's
my fault, but those are the ads.
I get tired of this shit. You go to
college, you know what I'm talking about.
Anyway. Um, yeah. So yeah,
subscribe to our youtube, you know,
got some subscribers on this.
Some good feedback, you know,
having to keep posting videos.
It does help that people will say echo
post videos in addition to just use
requesting peer pressure
like that. That's good. Yeah.
Um, so yeah, so I've tried to be need to,
that's a good, uh, also Jack was a store.
It was called Jocko store.
Jocko store.com on there.
We have t shirts. If you wear tee
shirts, you know, check them out.
If you're interested in anything on there,
get something. I'm not saying a bias,
I'm not saying, hey guys, go to
[inaudible] dot com and buy a t shirt.
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying go to Jocko store.com.
There's some shirts on their hoodies,
on their rash guards, patches,
some women's stuff, some tank
tops and whatnot. Travel mugs,
hats coming soon. Anyway, check them out
if you like go hats coming soon before.
Yeah. So far I've been impressed
by your turn times on that. Yeah.
It just depends on what you think soon.
Well would you say soon?
To me that means to me means three days.
Okay. So I grew up in quiet for hats.
Don't care. We knew from, no, no,
no. I'm not saying the toy in town.
I'm not saying that it is, but that's
not what I'm saying right now. Okay.
So quiet in Oman.
On Coy in Hawaii.
So on the end of Omal road is a,
I don't know what it is,
a church or religious center or something
and it says on the top it says Jesus
coming soon.
And that went up when I was I think
seven years old.
So soon is a relative term very
relevant or irrelevant relative. Yes.
It's a sliding scale for sure.
Let me tell you what hats I hope
get here before the return of Jesus.
Yes. That's the goal for sure. We can
make that happen if the officer nice.
Alright. Cause he got it summertime.
Yup. Now, right now it's summertime.
So we need hats to wear in the sun.
All right. To block the sun. Yes.
That's what had to do. Yeah. Got
You. So yeah, there it is. Jocko,
store.com if you see something on there
that you like, you recognize the layers.
Okay.
Grab something. Support.
Here's a little thing.
Jocko designed a shirt
design specifically 100%
too. By the way, by Jocko.
I even tried to put my little
pinky in there and some input. Yes,
straight up denied. I'm like, Bro,
do you know who manages that? Sure.
Yet it's not up. It's been
printed, but you know,
we went with it and 100% Jockos
designed 100% not really approved by me.
I mean it's approved, but like I tried
to like make my little considerations,
my little altered the nations and God
was watching out for them alterations.
I was worried about my creative input.
We overcame them. Totally overcame
them. Yeah. Trump. So I said,
we're making this shirt and that's
a direct order. What happened?
Now you're w you. Yeah,
you finessed it for sure.
But at the end of the day I looked up and
I was like, Dang my input on, you know,
the store that you know, I, I think, I
feel like I'm the manager of the store.
Apparently I'm wrong, but
that's cool. So anyway,
new shirt as a result designed by Jocko
Jocko, star.com. That's a good one.
Also, psychological warfare, if
you didn't know what that is,
it's an album with tracks of
Jacqueline's voice saying and telling,
helping. So what it's
doing, it's helped me.
No hope so people, myself
included, by the way,
through moments of
weakness if they arrive.
Arise. All right man.
All right. Yeah. So yeah,
if you're having trouble or one day,
if you want an alarm clock of me,
which people ask me for, just
get psychological warfare
instead. It is your alarm.
Yeah, that's it. That's why we meet it
because everyone was asking for that.
So there you have it. You don't
need to, you don't need it.
We're not going to make a ring tone,
I don't think. Yeah, we'll take, yeah,
technically you just said it. You just
said it as a ring tone and your guide,
it's, yeah, and it works
really good. Especially that,
well it depends on your weakness,
right? Or what kind of person you are.
So you know me, if you say, Hey Echo,
wake up at four 30 for
one year every morning,
one year there's going to be a day or two
where it's going to be harder than you
know, than another day. So you put it
on the track. What time do you wake up?
That's classified.
So if you have
a noon,
I woke up at noon on Saturday cause
you're still on Hawaiian time.
Did you wake up at noon? How could
you even do that? I didn't mean to,
it was, it's a long story. But
yes, my wife was like, hey,
it was good for you to join us or nice,
nice of you to join us.
Wife is ragging on you for a until
noon credit to her, she was just like,
she got two kids to take care
of sprawled out queen size bed,
getting African. Oh God. It's not
going to make a change. Nonetheless,
back to psychological warfare.
If you have, you know, if
you're on a d cool diet,
you're eating is clean. Boom. You get that
temptation one day at work, the donuts,
you don't, they bring the donuts, right?
We talk about these all the time. Yeah.
People just do that too. Okay. He
don't, Gracie, he run our wire.
Arlene,
he talks about um, like how you go to a
restaurant and they're like, oh, so cute.
The kids. Here's some, you know, here's
a cupcake for the kid's so cute. Right?
And people like overlook how
rude and uh, it's like, uh,
it's how much of a violation
that is rat poison.
You can feed them while you're on it. Hey
Look, look how cute your kids, our kids,
let me give them something super unhealthy
violation.
Anyway, that's what happens when people
bring donuts for work and thinking, Oh,
I'm going to do this for the office.
Not that I frown upon that.
I'm just saying put it into perspective.
Nonetheless.
If someone does that while you're at work,
boom,
you got to track where that to just
put it on real quick, but on your buds,
you know? So it's for you sugarcoated
lies, sugarcoated lies directly into your,
anyway, it's called psychological warfare.
Look at it on or look for it on iTunes,
Jocko Willink, Google play, Google play,
Amazon music, all that stuff. Yeah,
good stuff.
Wherever the MP3S are being
distributed or also on Amazon,
you can get Jocko white tea. And here's
a little verified purchase review.
Again, this means that the
person, this is verified,
it's 100% so here's the review.
As a tea guy, I am somewhat picky,
so I ordered some Jocko white tea.
I'm pretty sure the box was
Groundling when I opened it.
That's a verified review.
I brewed up tea and poured
it over ice. After which I went
on my bike for a training ride,
I was pulled over twice.
I explained that I had consumed some
Jocko white tea before I left and the
officer just nodded and said get after it.
The next officer was not so forgiving
and gave me a ticket for speeding limit.
So in summary,
this you can get pretty pricey if you
don't mind speeding tickets while you're
riding a bike.
So as just another thing to be careful
of if drink Jocko white tea and then you
get on a bike,
you've got to watch out that you don't
get speeding tickets cause you're gonna
be going a little faster than the speed
limit. That's the Jocko white tea.
Also on Amazon you can get
way the warrior kid and this,
this review here of way of the warrior
kid also verified purchase review from
Amazon.
This is the book I wish I'd read when
I was a kid and that's the same thing I
say all the time.
I work in schools and I've already
bought a spare copy to lend out to my
students.
I've also read it twice myself though.
I'm 39 year old man.
Side Note,
my pullups I have also improved.
So I'm telling you it's a kid's book.
Sure. That's what everyone says.
That's you know what it's set up.
Kind of looks like there's some lessons
in there from uncle Jake that we all
need so way of the warrior kid.
You can pick that one up. Also,
discipline equals freedom field manual.
Do you know what this book is about?
It's about getting after it mentally
and physically simple, straight forward.
So if you want to get after it,
get the discipline equals
freedom field manual.
Not a lot of fluff in there.
I'm going to tell you that right now.
Not a lot of fluff.
Straight forward.
Of course we got the book.
Extreme ownership is the book.
We refer back to a bunch on here.
Combat leadership before
your life for Your Business,
for your school, for your family, for you
own it,
and for your business or your team.
You can get us Ashkelon Front leadership
management consulting to help bring
leadership at your team to the next level.
That is Leif Babin who wrote
extreme ownership with me.
That is JP Denelle.
That is Dave Burke.
Both those guys had been on the
podcast to work both of those,
both those guys extensively in
the battle of Ramadi and myself.
Also at echelon front,
so that's what we do.
We go into companies and we
help you with your leadership
info at [inaudible] dot com if you're
interested also the muster in Austin,
Texas, July 13th and 14th
I'm the Barton Creek resort.
I think this might be sold
out by the time this airs.
It's a venue that's only 300 seats.
We've most of them,
if you don't get a ticket in time for
that check extreme ownership.com see if
you can still get a ticket for that one
and if you don't get a ticket in time
for that one,
that's okay.
Come to San Diego September 14th and
15th for Muster Zero Zero for that one is
also at the Omni hotel,
but the one in San Diego,
lots of folks are coming back to that one.
Lots of people that went to the first
monster in San Diego are coming back for
another go.
It's going to be awesome.
We will see you there and in the
meantime if you want to talk to us,
we are actually upon the
interwebs on Twitter,
on Instagram
and we going to see that one on day.
Facebooky Echo is at echocharles
and I am at jockowillink.
And thanks to everyone for
listening to the podcast,
but don't just listen,
go out,
wake up earlier or workout harder,
read more,
make yourself better.
A better soldier,
a better sailor, better
airmen, or a better marine,
a better police officer,
a better firefighter,
a better paramedic.
Make yourself a better engineer or
janitor or waitress or waiter or lawyer or
doctor or car mechanic or build builder.
Make yourself a better person,
better leader
every day.
And as Charlie may said,
on July 1st,
before he went over the
top into the raging hell,
that was the battle of the Somme.
He said,
it is a glorious morning,
and it certainly is.
All of them are.
Every morning is glorious.
So get out there and get after it.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.